this is jocko podcast number 185 with
echo charles and me jocko willik good
evening echo good evening
you get
one shot
and that's it
and in the end you're going into the
ground
[Music]
regardless
of what you believe the afterlife
consists of or what it doesn't consist
of
as far as what you get to hold on to
once you leave here
is nothing
and i implore people
all the time
to make it count
because this is it
this is the finals
there are no re-do's
[Music]
you can't hit the rewind button
and even worse you can't even hit the
pause button
there's no way you can stop the clock
from ticking
no possible way the countdown is
on and the days are finite
you only get so many
and then it's over
so until then
make them count
make all of them count
and on the podcast today i have a guest
a fellow frog man whom to the best of my
knowledge is doing his best
to make his
days
count
his name is mitch aguiar
and we just met each other
but like i said he's a frog man he likes
jiu-jitsu
he likes to get after it so my guess is
we should have some things to talk about
so mitch welcome to the podcast thanks
for having me
good good to meet you yeah good to meet
you 15 minutes ago yep
picked you up at the airport
i think we uh linked up some way on
social media
correct and you are in the ao
doing some training and so here you are
cool
where did you grow up
i grew up in virginia beach and then uh
was there until about 11 then moved to
maryland and uh live with my dad
was there until about 16 and then so
wait grew up in virginia beach parents
in the military yep my mom and dad were
both in the navy both in the nav that's
right check and uh my mom was an os
and my dad was a combat camera man with
uh dev group okay right on
and and so then you were there until you
said you were 11.
yeah i was in virginia beach until i was
11 they were divorced and my dad had
gotten out of the navy and was living up
in uh maryland working at the aberdeen
proving ground okay and doing high speed
photography there and uh
you know filming tank rounds and all
kinds of cool explosives and stuff like
that and she had like a wicked cool job
before it was cool a wicked cool job
yeah and uh
so i went up there and lived with him
for a while and then
around 16 uh moved up to
ohio my mom had uh moved up to ohio my
stepdad was also in the navy
and um he had gotten out and they'd
started a business up in ohio and i went
and lived with her up there and uh
finished out high school in ohio um
10th or yeah 10th 11th 12th grade
and then joined the navy from there what
what uh what was high school like what
sports were you playing i was playing uh
football basketball lacrosse
and uh
yeah that was it were you good were you
a good athlete i was a good athlete and
i was also into some
sports that weren't at our school i was
on a arm wrestling team all right and uh
dodge ball team like a traveling
dodgeball team really a traveling dodge
ball team it was it was by far my
favorite
like how how many games would you play
in dodgeball
in a day no in like a season what's this
season the dodge ball season well you
know there's practice obviously and uh
if if you take it serious like we did uh
we we practice like three times a week
and then we we would uh travel on the
weekends for tournaments what balls do
you use uh we would some some leagues
are different uh but mainly it's those
kickballs that you see so like the red
rubber ones yeah
how many people are on the team each
side um there was
it was like six or seven people per team
or and then we had like a couple
substitutes you know
in case there was injuries injuries yeah
just like any other sport man
you had your first string
starters
and then you but you didn't wrestle
i did not wrestle i didn't you i didn't
regret that i didn't run cross country i
didn't swim i didn't do anything in high
school that would uh
be useful in my
ongoing adventures well football
basketball i mean you're becoming an
athlete you're coordinating your
tradition
like uh just in general i would well i
would say that competition mindset you
know
um
that
and just yeah being an athlete overall
that was always something
that was just
ingrained in me you know my both my mom
and dad and they were really competitive
like always had us in sports growing up
my brother and i
and um
yeah i always loved the competition side
of things you know and i i
actually like hate working out still to
this day like i just i
don't really enjoy it but
if there's some sort of com competition
involved in it or you know
competitiveness that's that's what i
really like check
so you get done with high school
you're
and you what makes you join the navy
um honestly i was i was just bored uh i
was living in ohio and it sucked there
and uh
there was just nothing
there that i wanted how long after you
graduated high school did you join the
navy a couple months
did you did you go in the dive fairer
program to be in the teams or did you
just want to be in just in the navy
no i originally um i mean it it it
wasn't planned out at all uh i was i was
working three different jobs uh i was a
uh
a roofer which i really really loved
that was that was a great job
and
i worked at my
my parents like they owned a deli
convenience store kind of thing i worked
there and i was um
a lifeguard at kalahari and i and i was
a surf instructor you said kalahari i
already know that it's it's an it's the
world's largest indoor water park oh
okay and they have waves there yeah they
have a flowrider like a couple of
flowrider machines oh the thing that you
should water up the plastic yes type
thing yeah it creates an artificial wave
so i would uh
i was on the competition team and i
would like
give people lessons on how to ride that
thing
[Music]
so between that and dodgeball yeah you
were kind of dialed in oh yeah first of
first action that's right
that's a good setup so you recommend if
someone wants to get a career of special
operations they focus on dodgeball and
arm wrestling and
uh
surfing
awesome pretty much a formula for
success formula for success
and so you're you're you're doing these
jobs
and
you're you're not having a good time
with
yeah whatever i was you know
um not a very good uh
studious
uh student in high school um
you know
high school was more of like a
socialization for me like i really
enjoyed uh going there to socialize i
really enjoyed you know making friends
and i liked sports and uh
and i was always i always loved
working and making money you know like
school was just kind of uh in the way
i'd kind of you know at the time i just
had zero interest in
any sort of classwork whatsoever and um
i don't even understand how i somehow i
had graduated
and um
then
you know i was like yeah i'm definitely
gonna do something in life i don't know
what
i'm assuming it'll be good though you
know i just don't know what it is and
and my teachers were kind of in that
same
uh
mindset there you know half of them were
just like
man they're you're hopeless like there's
you're just gonna work at burger king
whatever and then the other half were
just like yeah you're gonna do something
great
it's definitely not gonna be in school
you know who knows what it is and i was
just kind of in that
you know glass half full
uh i was thinking the same thing and i
didn't know what it was honestly
like i said i was roofing and i really
loved uh
roofing but
yeah you know i was making minimal money
and um
i knew that that wasn't going to be it
so
i was in the area i knew that nothing
around the area interested me you know
there was nothing that i wanted to
pursue
around there i was young i was 18.
you know my my mom and dad were both and
my stepdad were were all in the navy
at
points in their life and you know had
talked about the benefits of the
military my dad was always trying to get
me to go in the military and i just
wasn't interested at all and um
yeah that was never really even a
consideration until quite literally like
i was just bored and the recruiter
happened to walk in catch me and
was like hey you want to join the navy
and i was like
sure why not
and uh
and i was at first i was going to do um
mastered arms like i was like oh you
know i've always i've always had like a
kind of respect for police um my
grandfather was a police police officer
my uncle is still a police officer
and that was something that i felt like
you know was a courageous
job and and a helpful useful one or
whatever you know and
i figured that i could i've always been
real protective as well so like i
figured that job would kind of
maybe be fitting for me
um
so
he he had asked me you know hey yeah you
want to join the navy and i was like
okay and i thought i'll go that route
and he was like well you look like
you're in good shape do you want to you
want to be a seal and i was like uh
what was the sneaky guys you know the
the the only thing i knew about seals
was uh
from that commercial where the where the
they're on the beach or it's a scene
when it's on the beach and the clouds
roll over the moon and then they they
disappear or whatever
and so that's all i knew about navy
seals and i was like oh those guys what
beer is this this was 2007.
[Music]
so you're watching the wars are going on
all through high school you're seeing
all that stuff take place
9 11 happened when i was in seventh
grade yeah you were probably
boots on ground or something there well
i mean i was
i was um
yeah i had been in for
like 11 years at that point because i
joined in 90. so i was born in 89 yeah
yeah
so i'm i'm a little bit older than you
are apparently
yeah so
did you not did you realize like um
so this was your first kind of
connection because for me when i was
growing up like every time some kind of
war event happened
i was all
bummed out that i wasn't there because i
was too young
and
that's just the way i was i was always
thinking about that i was always into
the military but you were kind of like
not i was the total opposite like i i
wanted nothing to do with with the
military i wanted nothing to do with
like i never
even thought about it my dad was just
you know he was in and he was a combat
cameraman with dev group so obviously he
was
you know
really involved with with it and uh
anytime he would try and talk to me i'm
just like i'm not interested i'm not not
gonna join the [__] military but you
don't know what what flipped the switch
just mega boredom yeah
just
just i just you know i was like well
worst case scenario i know i'm in for in
the navy for four years i'll go see the
world a little bit i'll you know gain
some
life experience and worst case i get out
and i'm [__] 22. yeah like who cares
i'm not going to college i know that you
know
high school was
i barely made it through that and just
not because i was stupid just because i
just
man it wasn't your scene oh my god i'd
rather do hell week 10 times in a row
than write an essay you know
so you get in the navy and
do you prepare at all
like for
i had never run like further than a mile
and like i all my sprint all my sports
stuff was all sprinting i mean those
dodgeballs are only you know dodgeball
courts are small yeah they're co they're
they're short so it's just i was always
a really fast sprinter
and uh
that was kind of all i really cared
about i i didn't even
i was also
i also like now looking back
how stupid i was and just how dumb you
are at 18. like you think you really
like no when you're 18 you really like
you're like man
you know you look back at when you're 10
and you're like i know so much now i
just compared to my seven-year-old self
compared to myself compared to my
eight-year-old self like i didn't even
know what i was doing now i'm a i'm a
man you know i know what what life's
about but at that point obviously now
i'm 30 looking back at that i'm just
like man you're so dumb but i really was
and uh
just really inexperienced with life i'd
never like i said run really further
than a mile
um i didn't even understand like that
people did that i'd heard about like
marathons and stuff but
um you know i remember when
you know when
when i had heard that i had to run like
a mile and a half for the pst i was just
like what in the [__] like why what and
then and then like
i told my dad that i signed up for the
the seal teams and i was like yeah i'm
gonna be a seal and he's just like you
have no idea what you just signed up for
i didn't even know i had to go to buds
and then
uh
so he he
i was just like yeah i'm gonna be a seal
what's wrong with that
and he uh he bought me the the 234
documentary
and uh we sat down and watched that and
i remember like just watching the the
four mile timed run
and i was just thinking like
is that even possible like
do people really do that and
i was just thinking like jesus christ
like this is
i'm gonna have to do all of this [__]
oh my god i better start
running i better start training so did
you start running and training yeah i
mean i i went out and uh you know
actually back up before i even saw that
the first um the first
introduction i had to buds was i or navy
seals in general
once i signed the like i signed up i was
like all right i'm gonna be a navy seal
i better do some research so i went out
and got
navy seals with charlie sheen
and i watched that and that was my very
first introduction to what navy seals
were
and i was just like
man looks pretty intense
pretty cool though
and uh
you know in the scene the scene in that
movie
they say it's buds but it's obviously
not because it's like in the woods and
they're like there's like grenades going
off and they're like
they're like uh army crawling under
barbed wire and and he's like this is
buds you know like it was just like this
crazy scene or whatever and i was just
thinking like damn i gotta go through
all that all right better
so i went out and bought some [__]
camo pants i bought some boots like just
leather boots
and um
there and i went for a run
uh
down my street and i remember it was
like a mile all right i did i was like i
have to run a mile and a half so i'm
gonna see
how this goes and i and i went and got
those pants and got suited up
and i was just thinking like oh man this
is going to be hard
but and then and then my dad got the uh
the 2 3 4 documentary and then that was
just like oh okay i really just have no
[__] idea what i just signed up for
and i was just thinking like damn
that looks really hard
but i already told everyone that i was
going to do this and i was just kind of
that
you know that's one good thing about
being 18 and you're just young and dumb
and stubborn
and
you know luckily i used
the the
the good of that to get through i guess
so you get in the i was going to say you
know my my
my uh
dive motivator was mike noss do you know
him
yes i i know who it is i don't i don't
know him personally but um well he's an
old vietnam frogman uh plank owner
at uh
damn neck and
he
he came in and he's a tall guy and he
walks with like a kind of a big limp
because he had like a hip replacement he
still swims like a fish
and uh he actually taught me how to do
the side stroke the day before my pst t
so it was like pretty steep learning
curve yeah that's that is i always tell
people um not to make decisions
when they're super emotional and so i'm
gonna start adding don't make decisions
when you're super just bored yeah
yeah you might end up at buds
so you show up there you show up the
buds
and
you must have you know obviously you
made it through was there any what was
it was tough for you and buds running
running was definitely uh
i mean obviously that's like what you do
the most of
and um
man it was just i went from no running
ever to
running my ass off just
everywhere and uh
and those timed runs man i was just
[__]
having a lot of conversations with with
jesus
those runs and just
you know giving it everything i [__]
had just to make the cut off on those on
those runs and then and then i
eventually i became like a pretty good
runner just from doing it and uh
um but yeah i was i was for sure captain
of the goon squad and uh but luckily all
those [__] dodgeball sprints were
paying off in the goon squad so
it was it was nice uh in the goon squad
i felt comfortable did you get rolled
for anything yeah i got rolled um
uh
for uh some i had real bad shin splints
from from
the the lack of running previous and uh
but other yeah got rolled dealt with
that and
like i said i picked up like from
running so much i just got good at it
and i was like young so
adapted well i guess yeah it pays to be
young and buds in my opinion yeah from a
physical perspective physically yeah for
sure with like dealing with uh overuse
injuries i mean because you're
definitely gonna
just
they're obviously just gonna [__]
ream your ass and then you have to get
up and go yeah i was talking to
uh
one of the medical guys there who came
from like a sports
environment like the i think the nfl was
either i think it was the nfl
and
do you remember the
i think it's patella femoral syndrome
did you ever know anyone that got that
there anyways there's a bunch of people
that get this this this patella femoral
syndrome you know there and he said yeah
at buds i would see
10 cases a week of patellar femoral
syndrome it's where your patella like
rubs against your
your
femur or something and he said in the
nfl you'd see like one of these
every year maybe one a year and so these
guys that would come to buds for from a
physical what was athletic trainer
perspective would learn so much because
they're just getting these mat these
bodies are just going through abuse like
no other bodies and so they see all
those all these common injuries that you
get your knees your your shoulders your
back like that's what you go to buds as
an athletic trainer you learn and as a
doctor you learn so much about how to
deal with these things because you see
10 times more than you would or more
than you would anywhere else yeah i
believe it but i've also talked to
people who say like i was young too
going through buds how old were you 18.
okay and so
you get the um you get the you get the
mind of hey i just do whatever they tell
me to do you know
but there's some people that say have
told me they didn't think they were
mature enough at 18 or 19 to go through
buds um i for sure was not
i don't want to say i wasn't mature
enough to go through because obviously i
did and i made it through however
you say like what or ask like what my
biggest struggle at buds was was
definitely my maturity
i mean physically like physically it was
running like just uh i was never a long
distance runner obviously
sprinting i was fast as [__] sprinting
and i was really strong on the log and
like the boats
the boats on heads was extremely
surprising to me i like i remember
seeing it on the videos and thinking
like
okay that's kind of weird like why are
they running around boats on their heads
like and then uh
i didn't think it was gonna be painful
because they're they're like inflatable
the rubber boats or whatever and then
when they put that thing on your head i
was just like jesus christ this thing is
smashing my [__] neck did the
instructors jump around in the boats
when you went through because you
stopped doing it at some point they
would uh like some of the little guys
would like jump and hang on the handles
and and [__] like that when when you're
running but yeah you definitely knew
when they were on the boats because they
got a lot heavier but they would um
what they would do when i went through
and they stopped doing this which is a
good thing they would they would be like
the boats would be lined up and we'd
have them in head carry and the
instructors would be in like boat one
and then they would just jump into boat
two and then jump in about three and i
remember hearing
when they did that to me a couple of the
times that they did it to me i heard
like this
deep kind of
inside my neck
and i remember thinking this is probably
not good and they stop doing it
thankfully because that's not healthy so
you actually used to be like six two
i i don't i don't know if i got shorter
but i definitely took some took some
damage
took some damage for sure yeah that was
that the boats on heads was probably the
most
surprising thing to me of how
like i just wasn't expecting it to be
that bad and uh but like the log pt
you know i was all i actually really
enjoyed the log pt i think probably
because from roofing you know i was
always carrying those 80 pound bundles
of shingles up the ladder and then like
i was the young guy on the crew so i was
the shingle [__] for [__] three
years
and you know everyone everyone on my
crew is in their 40s so
they you know i was the 15 year old when
i came on the crew and just a young
strong kid they they took full advantage
of it and just wherever they needed
shingles on the roof that's where i
hauled them up and uh so i was used to
carrying you know that the heavy load
and stuff and like i said i feel strong
i felt really good on that stuff and
mentally i was like
um
i just was super competitive and
that's what really
got me through buds was was just that
sheer competitiveness where did the
maturity level where could that have
tripped you up
were you like doing dumb stuff on the
weekends were you no not really um
because i mean i wasn't even old enough
to go drink or anything like that so uh
it was more just
kind of
not understanding
well one like i was different i was
different than most people there because
like you said you
wanted to be in the military your whole
life and like you wanted to be a seal
i'm assuming
did you yeah i mean as soon as i kind of
figured out what the seal teams were
yeah yeah so like
like that and like just how you are
you're very disciplined you're very you
know you're very militant i would say
and i would i would concur yeah and
i was like more of like a wild like free
spirit kind of
you know kid growing up and uh
and i i was not militant at all and so
and and i also like
getting through boot camp was difficult
for me because of that as well
you know just like i'm like why my my
question was like why do we have to
fold our makers or whatever we're
literally spent all day
undoing our bed and and remaking it i
was like i what the [__] is the point of
this like it's such a waste of time
and you know obviously it's all for a
reason and design but i just i couldn't
wrap my head around it so
that just lack of military bearing
and um
lack of maturity and understanding like
why things are the way they are and
you know the whole military structure
just you just do it and you don't
question stuff like that you know
that was probably
my biggest
hang up you know just i was different
than everyone i was young i was
i don't know
i didn't want to be a seal my whole life
you know some of these people like this
is like their dream and they've been
training for it for
whatever and i'm just kind of here
showing up and and guys are quitting and
and i'm not and you know and like
physically i was doing like a lot better
than some guys who like i said it was
kind of just like well i'm just here
whatever doing this and other guys it's
like this is everything to me
and
you know so
it's like i
check so you get done with buds
and you show up
and where'd you go team 10 team 10 yeah
right on and then how was that checking
into team 10.
um
it was it was cool but by that point you
know i'd kind of
like uh
obviously i was like all right i'm a
seal now and and i had been in the in
the pipeline for a while and kind of
getting in the
flow of things and the military and
and stuff like that but uh
yeah go i was super excited to check in
to team 10 um and i
originally i was going to go to team
five and then my i told my family you
know that i've uh got orders to five and
and they were all kind of bummed out
because they wanted they're all on the
east coast and um they were like oh man
you know we were hoping you'd come on
the east coast and i was like ah okay
i'll go to these coasts and i thought it
was like kind of cool too because
it felt like a
like a new like a new chapter because
like
you know the seal team won three and
five or and seven are right by the buds
compound so it was like you know i'd
been there and
been in this scene for the last two
years or whatever it was and
it was it was cool it felt cool to like
go across the country and like check
into a team and you know i just felt
like
like this is it this is a real deal so
that was super cool i felt it felt good
um
my troop was awesome and uh
and what was your what was your job in
your first platoon i was a heavy gunner
for sure
a-dub a knuckle dragger yeah yeah yeah
that's a classic
new guy
strong new guy guess what give him a pig
you're a big strong new guy got
something for you and i loved it yeah i
i i i embraced it i didn't think it was
like a bad thing you know and what year
is this now
2009. okay so you yeah you went straight
to the to the mark 48 no m60 for you
that's that's that's nice yeah we shot
60s and stuff but no like what like a
fam shoot with 60s or something yeah and
there were 60s on like uh humvees and
stuff like that and going through uh
vehicle stuff so there was still a
little bit of transition taking place
so you're a pig gunner your first
platoon how was your first workup
it was awesome uh it was definitely a
good time
uh what surprised you about
like going through work up being in a
sealed platoon what were what was
different than what you thought it was
what was different from how it was for
charlie sheen
um you know
it was it was a lot like the movie
it was it was it was great man i i i
thought it was a lot of fun um we got to
travel
travel the travel the country that was a
cool thing too about the east coast um
the training sites were kind of all over
all over versus the west coast it was
kind of like the same song and dance
like an island and
and uh what's the other one um
yeah you know like in the training the
training's like all the same sites and
uh
so going to the east coast i got to see
a bunch of new places and and that was
cool to me just kind of seeing the world
um
and the the brotherhood of like
being in the troops and
and stuff and you're you're rolling
around as a team i thought that that was
really cool
um
was there anything that was more
challenging like you know some new guys
they have a hard time in their first
platoon with whatever with land warfare
they have a hard time with cqc they'll
have a hard time with some you know
whatever sometimes it's like not easy
sometimes
you know you get a guy that can't dive
very well or whatever was there anything
that was any skill set that was hard for
you or did you pretty much which is i
would say most guys coming out of buds
and sqt like most of them are fine like
most of them get get they can they pick
things up pretty quick you know they
made it through all that crap they made
it through
sqt where you're getting screened right
again so most of the time but still
you'd still get guys showing up a
platoon that you know they wouldn't be
comfortable with this or they wouldn't
be great at that was there anything that
was tough for you
uh i would say like everything was was
tough i
i wasn't i wasn't a master at anything
other than my pig you know and uh
so
everything was was was somewhat
challenging for me but i also didn't
really struggle with anything too too
much
other than like my maturity like that
you know i was i checked into a seal
team before i could even go into a bar
you know and i didn't go to college or
anything like that so
i was
i was a 20 year old in a seal team yeah
you know um
so
yes i i had been through a lot
as far as like buds and skt and
you know that kind of forces you to grow
up um to an extent but
seals like to party too and uh
and i kind of
that was probably my biggest challenge
was just my maturity and just kind of
learning when
to to
lock on and
and you know when it was time to like
chill out did you ever get caught did
you ever get in trouble did you ever get
arrested
uh i did get arrested and not in my new
guy platoon i got arrested in my uh and
when i was in my second platoon
uh i got into a bar fight um
this these guys it was actually three
three dudes uh
had just started mouthing off to
one of my platoon members wife it was
him and i and uh my girlfriend at the
time and and his girlfriend at the time
now or wife and uh
we were coming out of the bar and they
just had had a couple drinks and they
had come over and said some
disrespectful [__] to them and
you know i i just was feeling froggy a
little bit and
and uh
didn't let it slide
and ended up whooping their ass and beat
up three people outside of a bar and got
arrested but
but your first platoon you you managed
to keep your nose clean or at least as
far as
the actual law go the actual law
enforcement goes yeah no trouble
and then where was that so you did your
work up where did you guys go on
deployment to your first deployment
afghanistan
and
when you were going to afghanistan
were you going did you go as a whole
troop to afghanistan uh yep yeah all
three of our platoons went
yeah it was it was kind of an
interesting um
thing because
uh
it was in 2011
and
i don't know if you
you said you got out in 2010 i did yeah
well yeah there was
i'm sure you'd heard about they uh they
wanted us to
somehow get on the army schedule
and uh so it was us and team seven
mm-hmm and um
we ended up basically doing two
deployments back to back
and got
synced up with the army or something
like that i don't i don't know all the
all the
you know mumbo jumbo that actually took
place but or why why we did it but uh
they told us kind of right before it was
like two months before we left they're
like hey um just kidding you guys are
going to go to afghanistan and we're
going to need you to stay there for
basically a year
and we're like oh [__] okay
so uh
we went there and uh
it was
it was an interesting
deployment for sure because
my platoon
um
we were the furthest outposts from any
major base in afghanistan
and uh you know
were
basically roughing it the whole time we
were out there did you guys take over an
outpost somewhere or did you guys
establish one uh we took one over that
had just been established like literally
a couple months ago you know so there
was there was nothing there we were
sleeping in tents still
no running water no no nothing like that
and then um
i think around months
seven or eight of our
deployment we packed up and went 15
miles north and
set up a new
uh site so it was literally just
[__]
roughing it the whole time
uh you know air dropping our food in and
and no running water the whole time and
what what type of ops were you doing
um
we were we were doing all kinds of stuff
uh and i was lucky enough to kind of we
got to they shifted our guys around too
so like we got to all like kind of
experience
different things because we all had a
different kind of mission set
and different we were all in all three
of our platoons were in different areas
of afghanistan so
um i got to kind of do
a lot of everything
so were you guys going out on patrol
from your from your forward operating
base was that yeah and yeah pretty much
daily
and you were uh interacting with the
local populist type thing yep yeah
trying to establish relationships yeah
we did that for a little while that was
uh
really dumb
that you
don't because you didn't feel like you
made any progress didn't make any
connections yeah i mean and in my
opinion i i just thought it was like
kind of a a waste of time and um i just
i just felt like we could have been
doing a lot
more
uh stuff or or better stuff with our
time and and training and all that and
it was just like a super dangerous uh
area to be in you know it was in uh
hellman and
as we basically just lived in a [__]
minefield you know and it was just
ieds everywhere just as a constant
threat so
you know and we were going on these long
patrols every day and and uh
and all these all these ops we were
doing and hitting these villages that
were
just riddled with ieds everywhere and
you know getting contacted
you know on you're basically just stick
out like a sore thumb
there you know so
uh
i mean you know how it is overseas i i
didn't feel
real comfortable with that like and
it sucked uh
being in a minefield like just every
step just please don't blow please don't
blow up please don't blow up please
don't blow up
you know for a year
yeah did you guys did you guys hit any
ieds uh yeah
yeah we encountered a couple ids and
um
so that was shitty
yeah
and the the enemy
did you have a feel for
who was bad and who was good when you'd
go out
no definitely not um there was i mean
because like literally there was there
was uh times where
you know we'd be in the village [__]
shaking hands with people and then
you know on the way out get contacted
get in a fire fight and then [__] go
back and look and
oh it's the same guys that we were just
shaking hands with that are [__] dead
you know
and
so
it was
it was hard to
it was really weird to like
get
rev ramped up and everything as he's
like
you get in this mindset of this warrior
mindset
you know that you're going to war and
you're going to this [__]
land where every everyone is you know
your enemy and blah blah blah and then
it's like oh just kidding let's let's
try to help some of these people or
whatever and and
the
you know the good in you is like okay
yeah i wanna i wanna help people and and
stuff like that and and do what i can um
to help these people out and then if
they're getting like bullied essentially
by the
by the taliban or whatever like that's
not cool but
i just felt like
it was
it was really weird to to be there and
go there with that mindset and then have
to [__] like try to help people and
then when you try to help people they
don't want your help and
you know and they [__] shoot at you
and and [__] like that so it's like
and then you're expected to like go out
and
try and help these people again and it's
i don't know it was just like a weird
it's a weird dynamic
and would you go when you said you would
move positions were you going from like
would you like switch platoons and go to
a different operating base yeah
and then you'd spend some time there
with them
and and then do operations with them and
then after a little while go to a
different one as well yeah yeah we we
rotated our all of our guys just to so
we could all get
you know
experience doing other things like
working with the commandos or you know
uh
training the fit training fed um or
doing the vso stuff and
yeah it was cool i i i enjoyed that just
because it broke up the monotony of
every day you know going on patrols
doing the same thing seeing the same
places or whatever and dealing with the
same threats uh
it just
it keeps you kind of from getting
complacent i felt like so
especially for the 11 month yeah so i
was definitely happy to
move and and do new things and work and
like and it was cool too because
on the base that we were at
in afghanistan it was literally like a
hundred yards by a hundred yards
that was your
that was like our camp it was like being
in prison you know but worse like
because we're getting shot at too and
like
if you when you go outside to
go get your [__] food that they
airdrop in
you know you're worried about stepping
on ieds like we found ieds literally
right outside of our compound you know
so it was a constant threat always and
uh
and like i said like going to get our
air dry it was just a lot of work too
because not only
it was like we were seal bees you know
we had to like build our we had to like
build our camp
and also like all the stuff that came
with that like
going and getting our
our uh supplies that would air drop in
and and being out there
you know you only get ring routes and
and stuff you only get air drops every
once in a while and uh
so when when [__] would come in it was
like all hands go
work on this and then also you got to
prep your [__] and get ready for the the
op tonight or tomorrow or whatever and
um
and i remember just
i remember i have a video of one of our
big air drops
coming in and you just see like three or
four pallets just burn in and just
explode and you know it's like always
it like all the water bottle
palettes are fine but it's that one with
like the goodies
you know it's like oh man you know
that's the one that burned in and it
just [__] hits the ground explodes
and you see like all the rippets or
something you know something that people
are looking forward to just explode and
you're just like [__]
i i don't know i just accepted that this
was my life so
whatever i wasn't i wasn't thinking
about the time too much
and then um
i just you get into a rhythm you know
and we got to we got to go home for r r
that was cool
took a little break but it was like
bittersweet you know go home for [__]
two weeks and
like i've just been playing in this
minefield where everyone's trying to
kill me for the last six months and come
home for two weeks and like to normalcy
and you're just like you know literally
just fly straight from there no
decompression or anything and then now
you're back in normal society with your
family and and by the way you're leaving
in 11 days to go back yeah and then
you don't get comfortable because we're
going right back over there so that was
like kind of like
it was bittersweet and uh
got back over there but that was cool
too because i was like all right i'm
[__] halfway through like it's
downhill now you know so
that it kind of definitely fired me up
to to finish out but then uh
towards the end we were there for all
four seasons so we saw literally
all four seasons this is interesting
and um
by the end of it
by the end of it uh
i remember when the ring route came to
pick me up to go out
uh i remember flying away from from the
base that we were at and just thinking
like i felt kind of sad like like almost
like when you move away from somewhere
and like i've moved my whole life i've
moved around a lot so i was like damn
like this has been my home for the last
year
you know i'm kind of bummed to
to to leave but
[__] this place i can't wait to go home
yeah i got kind of lucky because i had
been in the navy for a while when
when i deployed to iraq and especially
my second deployment to iraq where i was
in ramadi and and like i
i
you know sometimes people will say oh i
look back and i i wish i would have
appreciated it more
you know people say that about certain
parts of their life
i don't have that at all like i 100
appreciated every single day i was there
was like this is this is the the best
part of my whole life is right is what's
happening today right now you know so i
got kind of lucky in the fact that you
know even talking to the guys that were
new guys on on uh that deployment to
ramadi they they just kind of
they were like
from then on they'd be saying damn you
know i thought that's what every
deployment was gonna be like it was and
it was
they just didn't have that same
perspective of hey man this is
like
this target-rich environment where we're
getting to do
what everyone's dreamed of doing their
whole life and you're gonna do it all
the time
that doesn't happen you know it doesn't
happen like that usually you know it's
hard and so i was pretty lucky in the
fact that i
i i was i could appreciate it yeah i
know as far as the work went like i was
as far as like like
being a seal and working there like that
that was awesome you know and i was
uh you know one of the biggest like
i say concerns i had or or not or even a
concern was just like a question to
myself was
you know
what what how am i actually going to
react in combat you know what i mean
because everyone everyone likes to think
that they're
ideally you know in a situation of [__]
popped off you know i'll be the i'll be
the guy who will you know hold have my
[__] together and and be that you know
the rock or whatever you know what i
mean
and uh some people crumble you know and
i saw that
as a seal like
that that was kind of my i was always a
realist you know was like i've never
been shot at i've never been in a
gunfight or whatever so
um
i definitely you know i i feel like i'm
not a coward and i feel like i would
step up and do do what i got to do and
perform i feel like that but i don't
know it for sure you know what i mean
and um
so that was
that was definitely
when it happened in a in a you know and
i did i i stepped up and and felt very
pleased with with how that all went down
and and all the combat and everything
that i had been involved with like that
was
definitely um rewarding to me you know
like as a seal and and as a man just and
as a warrior just like okay
like i felt legit you know i felt like
fulfilled in that sense um
so the work
the work was really
good
but just as far as
being in that environment like
uh the ieds was really like the ieds and
the [__] like invisible enemy was
kind of
um discouraging you know it was like it
felt like we just had so much
risk
you know for not a whole lot of reward
and uh like which is different like i
would say oh i feel like in like ramadi
was like a different just way different
environment
um but
yeah i don't know
yeah no that's that's the that's the way
insurgents are supposed to fight right
you're not supposed to see them they're
just supposed to pick away at you the
death of a thousand cuts
you know indirect fire ieds and snipers
and they don't want you to ever see them
and and that's what they want and just
to slowly pick away because they don't
care about human life they don't value
human life and here we are you know
every time we lose someone it's it's a
tragedy
and they don't care if they lose guys or
not they don't they don't care they
don't care if the civilians get killed
don't care about any of that
and so that's why they have
that's why they have an advantage in
those situations a psychological
advantage is hey
we we don't care if you kill us and by
the way we know you care about your
people and so we're going to pick away
and you're hopefully you're never going
to see us and we don't care we're going
to blow you up and
we don't care yeah that i mean
that was pretty apparent i mean uh
because a lot of the ieds that went off
were
you know local villagers stepping on
triggered by civilians you know and uh
then that that just happened all the all
the damn time and uh
and we would we would help them you know
we would we would aid the wounded and
stuff like that and they'd like get
pissed at us and we're like we didn't
plant that [__] you know
like get mad at them not us
yeah that's that that insurgency thing
is
but yeah and like hard to deal with it
was it was just super frustrating to me
like uh
it was super frustrating to me
dealing with like
the politics involved
with war
and um
you know i felt like we absolutely could
have done things
to give us more of an advantage but it
seemed like they were more concerned
with
politics and [__] like that you know
as more than more than like the safety
of us
and i just felt like we could
you know there's no reason why
we should be going out in the daylight
period you know we we train
like why not
fight like we train and oh because you
guys got locked down from doing stuff at
night right is that right we got to do
night [__] but we also did a lot of day
[__]
and i you know to me it was just like
why the [__] are we doing this
like we have night vision
why are we going out there did you have
afghan forces with you sometimes
a lot of times we did well
yeah
we we had to work a lot in ramadi in the
daytime um and the the main reason why
we have worked well there's a couple big
reasons why we worked in the daytime in
ramadi
which as you as you just pointed out is
a huge tactical disadvantage compared to
being out at night where we can
literally see and the enemy can't i mean
it's
but in ramadi you know we had to work
with iraqi soldiers who didn't have
night vision so they didn't have
flashlights they would have like one
flashlight for every four people and
we'd eventually got them flashlights and
stuff but
anyways it was it was a problem because
to go out at night with them it was they
were blind and so now you're you're like
at a you're at this the same
disadvantage
because you're trying to you got people
that can't see mixed with people that
can see
and they're not getting anything out of
it they're not improving their skills at
all
and they're just horrible
yeah and they were they were not not
good not good and so that was one reason
was to take them out in the daytime we
to get him to operate we had to go out
with him in the daytime and the other
big one was the enemy knew that we owned
the night and so the enemy in ramadi
they didn't come out at night they came
out in the daytime so if you wanted to
kill them you had to go out when they
were when they were moving and so that's
when we went out and you know we we did
both and we did a ton at the night as
well and also you know we take advantage
of the night to get in good positions
we know when
and then during the daytime they would
come out to fight and you know they'd
get it
yeah we had we had uh our we had we were
working with the commandos and they had
night vision um but like i said they
were just terrible
and uh
like one of one of them almost shot me
um
on and off uh we were actually in a
helicopter flying to target and uh
it was one of their heavy gunners and um
he uh
it was around midnight and we were
flying in a chinook to
to the target and uh i was just kind of
nodding off just you know
just just trying to you know catch a
little nap on the ride to the op and
it's pitch black in the in the helo
obviously and uh
all of a sudden it's just
crack you know like
four or five rounds crack off and
the guy next it was the guy next to me
and thank god he had his barrel down and
uh like literally just shot like four or
five rounds like less than six inches
from my feet
and there's just holes in the bottom of
the the bird and shot the comms out of
the helo and everything and
at that point i was just like [__] you
know i was it was just kind of used to
[__]
being shitty and just reached over and
took the rounds out of his gun and just
that was the safest weapon yeah and just
like come over comes like yeah [__]
commandos a.d
you know everyone's just like whatever
but
uh
so then we changed like all right no
more commandos rolling hot in the birds
you know on the way to target uh target
and uh
so we we we had changed that
so then the next one we did
we [__]
got to we uh
got to our
our uh target bird landed get out and
do our formation and all of a sudden and
it's like a total brown out you know
because afghanistan is super dusty and
everything there and uh
the the hilo
lands we're all getting out in our
formation and it's total brown out and
then all of a sudden
we hear
[__] rounds going off
because the the dudes
loading their
pigs like all of a sudden had a runaway
gun or whatever we're we don't know if
we're getting contacted like you can
hear it's outgoing but like why why is
there outgoing fire when we're in
filling
you know are we getting contact or
what's going on and it's just these guys
are [__] stupid with their weapons
and
yeah so it's always always something fun
always good
so you wrap up that deployment
and
come back to
come back and roll into your next
next platoon yeah come back and uh
roll into the next platoon and um
i always wanted to how was that how was
that coming home now you're now you're
home you did the two weeks in the middle
how was the transition when you got home
it was uh
it was it was rough um
i was definitely dealing with some
ptsd i would say and uh
i was i was definitely kind of angry um
i was i was angry
it was a weird weird weird emotions um
because i i kind of was kind of pissed
off at like
uh america
like like
not america as a whole but like
i felt like uh the politics you know
like i said earlier i felt like they
really
um
cared more about
or they just didn't really give a [__]
about our safety i felt like uh you know
it's one thing like obviously we're
doing a dangerous job but
why
why on earth are we
not giving ourselves every advantage
that we are capable of
you know like like the night vision and
stuff like that and
and a lot of times we would
capture people
um
who we knew were bad you know talking to
our intel guys and they're like 100
like this dude is a [__]
terrorist like he's a bad dude like
everyone in his phone you know they rip
apart their [__] and like ev every one
of his contacts are bad you know like
this guy's definitely a an ied maker you
know whatever
and
so
we've got these guys captured but then
we have to turn them into the afghan
government which we also know is corrupt
and
then all of a sudden these dudes
are
out
on the streets again
in a couple months time
and making ieds that
you know me or my brothers could step on
and [__] that's a wrap
and
you know
uh
caleb nelson was a seal that died on our
deployment from our team and
it's just kind of
you know
life and death and
war it just puts things into perspective
and uh it really made me angry that
you know like
caleb couldn't come home because of an
ied and like
we're letting these people
go
and and i just felt like we weren't
being
utilized fully and uh and like
like it was costing us
and so i was like really angry about
that and um
and then
also just kind of
being in that environment for a long
time just
it's different you know
different mentality and then coming home
to america and like people just don't
understand how good it is here and it's
like a [__] fairy tale you know and
and trying and listening to people talk
and complain about
about [__] here and i'm just like
you don't even have to you don't even
you just walk down that sidewalk and
didn't even give a [__] where you
stepped like you didn't even care
because you're not worried about
anything you're not worried if there's
an ied there like you have running water
you took a shower today
you [__] i had to burn my own [__]
you know and
so i was just like
a lot of anger
dealing with that and i was drinking a
lot like uh
and i also felt like
i felt like seals were the only ones
that kind of
understood and got it
and then also being over there
in afghanistan i saw
you know kandahar the main base in
kandahar was like a [__] it was like
a little town you know there's like
flag football leagues and shopping and
tgi fridays people having birthday
parties and [__] like that and
you know that's where that's where like
tim mcgraw flies in to do the concert
for the troops and [__] like that you
know and it's like oh is this where
we're staying eating like kings you know
and they're like no no no
you're going out there
so then you know
that's where i that's where i was and
that's where where me and my boys were
you know
living in the sock
and living doing some serious [__]
shitty living you know and and working a
job that was dangerous as [__]
every day and then just seeing that kind
of [__] like
i don't know i just i felt like
before i had gone over overseas i was
like real
like thank you for your service to
everyone i saw you know and and
afterwards i was just kind of the
opposite
and uh was like [__] all these
[__] man
so
i was just disgruntled and whatever and
uh
and peop you know i'd hear people talk
about ptsd or this or that and i'm like
what the [__] are you what are you
afraid of you know you were on a main
base that like
wasn't it's not even a thing like
you didn't experience war
but that was like just kind of
immaturity at the time and and like like
i said me being just kind of disgruntled
and
um
dealing with that and i was drinking
like heavily uh
and
i was just a super aggressive person and
it wasn't like a good
it wasn't good for my friends and family
like people i cared about or whatever
and like i said i felt like seals were
kind of the only ones that understood
and then even amongst seals i felt like
only the ones who
who had to live so shitty like we did
like our platoon you know no running
water for a year and like
like just
living in that environment was super
rough and i felt like they were the only
ones who understood but then again it's
like i just spent a year with these
[__] in a hundred by a hundred
foot you know
place i don't want to see them
you know
and uh so i just kind of felt alone a
little bit you know and uh
whatever
dealt with that
got got through that and doing better
now and
and i was like kind of
disgruntled towards people
claiming ptsd and all this kind of [__]
uh for years after that and then
actually some random um
uh
this random chick at a dinner i was at
she was uh
in the army or something like that and
and
she had she was talking about ptsd and i
was just thinking like jesus christ what
the [__] are you
what what is it you know
and i kind of said my viewpoints on it
and she was like well you know
fear is relative
and you know like
you were you were
seriously trained and stuff for for war
and
and to be in that environment and you
know some people weren't and
like fear is relative like this like
being in a gunfight to you
you know and versus like just being in
that country like could be the same
amount of fear or more for that person
and i was just kind of like you know
i never really thought about it that way
okay i'll change my mind
yeah well war is different for everybody
and it's i remember my first deployment
to iraq we we
we traveled a lot and we went to a lot
of different places and so we'd go from
like the incredible
palaces that had been taken over that
had subways and starbucks and then we
you know the next day we'd be out at
some out station somewhere there'd be an
oda team just living in you know the
most horrible living conditions and then
the next day you'd be with uh some
random marine corps company out in some
other forward operating base and again
they're just living like in hell and
then you come back to another another
like main fob and it's all luxurious and
nice and i mean it just it kind of is
what it is for sure you know it just
kind of is what it is and that actually
makes sense what that female said about
you know
hey it's
different people are there they're
they're there for different reasons
you know like
we joined the seal teams because what we
want to do is go out and go on patrol
with a machine gun that's like 100
percent right of why you joined the seal
teams someone that goes you're hoping
for a gunfight like you're praying for
war yeah and i remember like being out
there man i i remember my very first op
um
when i
we we flew into this to to this village
and
i remember being like super nervous like
holy [__] i'm i'm a [__] navy seal
and i'm actually going on my first
mission like
holy [__] and i'm just thinking like uh
when we land we we landed at like 3 a.m
or something and we we offset like way
far away
but i was thinking like
it's going to be guns blazing as soon as
this helo lands
i jump out the helo and i'm just like
full-blown ready for war like what uh
bring it on let's go where's bin laden
and it was just pitch black
quiet and sat there for [__] hours
and you know until the sun came up
nothing happened i was like god damn it
i was so disappointed you know like i
was looking forward to like war and then
you know
obviously we got we got plenty but uh
i yeah i remember just being real antsy
to to get in a fire fight and
you know to to do what i've been trained
to do and put my training to the test
you know and
yeah it's different for other people who
are not experiences may vary
there's no doubt about that so dude when
you went to uh bat when you got home and
you got put into a new platoon did you
guys keep a core group of guys from your
from your previous platoon together or
was it like brand new uh yeah no we we
had guys that stayed and and some went
you know to trade it and
some screened and standard turnover dude
[__] few few core guys stayed together
four or five or whatever yeah and then
you guys got a new chief and a new oic
yeah assistant platoon commander yeah
yeah that was man god thank god i
i am so i so do not miss
having [__] 20 bosses you know in the
military and then
every you know at the drop of a hat it
can change and then all of a sudden it's
like nope
new flavor we're we're uh now we're you
know it's like oh jocko's now our
[__] commander so we're all waking up
at 4 30 and
going to pt it's like what the [__] when
did this happen
this is [__]
oh check
and and so you get you'd do another
workup
yeah yeah and uh i i uh i'd always
wanted to be a a dog handler oh sweet
yeah and i i i tried to volunteer to be
a dog handler as a new guy and and they
said no because you know they want your
guy
here's your dog
his name's 48.
and
make it bark
so
yeah now i got to um
to do the dog handling thing and um
was super super excited about that and
uh it was it was honestly such a great
time
um i had a badass dog and i was this
first handler and uh
yeah it was
it was super cool because
you know
well one i was
i was in one platoon wonder so i'd
already kind of gotten that afghanistan
gotten some combat under my belt and
um you know i was the classic worst
the the worst guy in the teams is a one
platoon wonder
and uh so i was full-blown just one
cruise wonder you knew everything 100
and uh and i got a [__] dog so
watch out
stellan no
my dog was super cool and um
they like uh there the
there were six of us that went over to
work with the dogs and we all got along
really well and uh
and that was super cool because now
you're not a new guy finally you know
and i mean even on our deployment in
afghanistan
we were still [__]
doing new guy
[__] yeah you're you're a new guy you're
a [__] new guy i couldn't [__]
believe it i'm like
we literally they made us shovel rocks
one time like like a whole
like uh dumpster or a dump truck full of
rocks and they just we just moved it
from one pile and just tent over like 10
15 feet to the right and we just moved
the pile of rocks to this make a new
pile 15 feet to the right and it was it
was a disciplinary thing it wasn't
you know all the new guys your
attitude's not good
and we're just like are you [__]
serious like
we were just in a firefight with you
like you know we're not like we're
expecting to like be boys now and
they're like shut up new guys
your attitude sucks go shovel rocks
and we're just like god damn it you know
when we were like literally having to
burn [__]
you know burn our own [__] uh we had we
had uh barrels that we had wrapped that
cord around and cut in half and
um
filled with diesel fuel and those were
our those were our [__] but they
needed burned so when uh when the when
the new guys
you know when when we didn't uh
have the best attitudes or
our attitudes weren't up to par we
shoveled rocks and burned [__]
so i was definitely happy to not be a
new guy anymore yeah um but anyway yeah
so i was one between wonder had a dog
and
uh
got to go through another workup with
the dog so that was super cool and and
got to go through dog training school
and and learn about the dogs and
and um
yeah
unfortunately like right right before
it was we were on like pre-deployment
leave and
they had told us like hey change of
plans we're going now we're going to
uconn
so
uh we don't need the dog anymore ugh
and i was like [__] man this isn't like
a piece of equipment i mean that's
essentially how the navy looks at them
they are they are equipment but
you know obviously it's a dog and you
you form this like super strong bond and
attachment with them just like they're
your pet
and uh my dog was super awesome and
i'd worked with him so much you know it
was like a robot it was like a
it was so cool and um
i was [__] so pissed off when they
just dropped that on us and it's just
like yeah they hand the leash over to
someone else
and
yeah so
did that and uh then went to uconn and
and
you know a lot of guys were [__]
super pissed off that we were going to
you come and you know i i was
definitely looking forward to using my
dog and and
you know doing that in afghanistan but
you know that is what it is you you know
i definitely knew that there wasn't
i i didn't see any value in just
bitching about it and uh it seemed like
that was like the common thing was just
it was it seemed almost like if you
weren't bitching about it then you were
looked at as a turd and like if you you
know if you weren't bitching louder than
the guy next to you then you're
you're you know oh man i'm so
disappointed we're not going to
afghanistan yeah me too i'm super
disappointed like yeah well i can't even
sleep at night well well i don't even
want to [__] go you know like well
you know it's just yeah i just realized
just to shed some light on to everyone
so when you deploy in a sealed platoon
or a sealed troop you can deploy
different parts of the world sometimes
you deploy to places like iraq and
afghanistan which as we just kind of
discussed that's where everybody wants
to go
well 95
well you never know what the real number
is because there's some people don't
want to go but there's there's the
attitude most guys want to go and they
want to go fight
but there's also you have to deploy to
other parts of the world where there's
no war going on you might just deploy to
the pacific or you might deploy in this
case eucom is for european command so
that's going over to germany and doing
doing things out of germany and
different parts of europe and it's
definitely
not a high threat environment
and so yeah and that's the way it goes
sometimes
there's a mission that has to be done
and it's a different kind of mission
you're going to build relationships with
other countries and you do these
exercises and do training
events but it's not generally what guys
are excited to do in the seal teams so
there's always
there's always a you know i always get
asked that question when i when i go and
talk to seals is hey my guys are going
here how do i keep them on you know how
do i keep them how do i keep them
engaged when yeah no one wants to do it
or they don't care about it it's like
yeah you got to work through that it's
definitely it's definitely a challenge
because you know i would imagine
especially if you know like that you're
going to ucom and then starting that
workup because you still have to go
through the workup and train
as if you know your [__] life depends
on it and that you're going to war
and you know that you're
the elite
you know warrior and you have to be
ready for anything so you like obviously
our training is
uh
developed around that but then
having to keep up that motivation like
it's it's one thing when you're like
[__] dude this training sucks and it's
i'm tired it's hot i'm you know i'm like
[__]
covered in [__] or whatever and i've
gotta hike 12 miles carrying this thing
and it's like well
you got to do it though because we're
going to [__] war like this is
serious you know but then it's like
going to uconn man why the [__] are we
even training today so you know what i
mean
but uh
i don't know so
i didn't really have that that attitude
though i was kind of excited to you know
i had just gotten we just done that that
year deployment to afghanistan and it
was you know my platoon was the one that
was
really really shitty shitty living the
other two platoons were
in nice bases that they were like had
awesome gyms like good food and
and stuff like that and uh
you know so i i wasn't i wasn't too
terribly upset about it obviously like
everyone wants to go work and and kill
bad guys like a champion but uh
you know when you when you got to do it
that and it is what it is you might as
well [__] enjoy it that's why i feel
you might as well make the most of it at
what point did you start jiu jitsu
i started i started jiu jitsu actually
um in buds uh
that was my introduction um to buds one
of our bud's instructors
was
he he was interested in jiu jitsu and
liked it or whatever and uh so as a
punishment
one day we had to do wet and sandy
jiu-jitsu like introduction to jiu-jitsu
and
like a lot of guys were were not
enjoying it because
one if you've never done jiu jitsu
you're 100 gonna get [__] up by anyone
who has done it
and
we were wet and sandy so it was like
just cold and wet and miserable and
sandpaper like grinding on each other
you know
but i actually really enjoyed it i was
like holy [__] this is pretty cool and
uh
one of the guys
there was two guys in our class that
were
both uh really high level wrestlers like
in high school and um
and they were probably like on a blue
belt level you know they were probably
like 135 145 pounds and at the time i
was around 185 190 pounds i had done
never done jiu jitsu ever or wrestled or
anything like that and uh i always
punched you know i knew i punched hard
because i've been in a lot of fights
like street fights and [__] and bar
fights but
um
or at that point sorry it wasn't bar
fights it was like high school fights
um
dodge ball fights right
i did get in a dodgeball fight once no
[__]
and uh
so anyway these
these little guys just tied me in a
[__] knot and i was just
so impressed
like
because looking at these dudes i would
be like 100 i'll [__] this guy up in a
fight
and
we
you know they were like all right no
striking no no no punching but we're
gonna grapple and i'm like okay and
we're grappling and they're just
completely [__] me up and i was like
thinking oh my god if these
little itty bitty men
can tie me in a knot like this and just
make me helpless like imagine what i
could do if i learned this
so
i started uh rolling with one of my
friends who uh was like six to
240 pounds at the time and just super
aggressive and
he was probably around a blue belt level
of knowledge um
maybe not quite a blue belt you know but
he knew definitely more than i did
and
we you know he was really aggressive too
and and and he was like all about
rolling um so we would roll nogi
and he would just concentrate this was
where
and this is in buds or in buds and then
buds and then sqt um you know buzz was
the introduction to it and i was like
whoa i i [__] love this is cool and
then i started talking to one of my
classmates who was
also into it and you know he had done he
had done some training before the navy
and like i said he was around a blue
belt level so when you got to team 10
did you start training immediately at
one of the academies no i didn't start
training um at one of the academies
until after afghanistan i came back and
uh because one of the guys one of my
like my c daddy he was uh he was a
purple belt
at the time and
um we would roll on occasion you know
and and he would be like and he would
tell me like man you have like great
you know aggression and an ability and
all this [__] but you you got to go to
an academy and and learn you know i'd
only learned
just from that guy
that dude beat my ass over and over and
he would literally like just
just [__] get on top pressure grind
arm triangle you know and he'd be like
all right man
you know i got on top and i [__] i'm
trying to
squeeze like that don't let me do that
again
i'm like all right got it yeah try
harder try harder you know you you yeah
you gotta do something right you're not
doing anything you know what i mean so
it was one of those so uh
i had gotten pretty good
at just getting my ass kicked and
dealing with a big large human or
whatever
so then when i actually showed up to an
academy
um
i had been doing that for a couple years
you know with him and never put on a
ghee or anything like that
but then afterwards yeah he was like you
got to join gym so i joined the gym put
on the ghee and and then really like
that's when my jiu jitsu i i say really
started my journey
and that was in 2012. did you have
someone to train with on your ucom
deployment
um yeah i trained with my c daddy he was
there and uh
i trained
in uconn like we were obviously going to
different countries so i would go and
and hit up different gyms and the
different countries and then all the
other uh the other countries seal teams
you know that we worked with there's
always someone who's into combatives you
know so i would basically just find out
who that guy was who wants to get
something yeah who wants to get some and
then we'd roll the mats out and [__]
train and and i was trying to get guys
into jiu jitsu back then and i was
telling him you know it's a great
workout and people are just looking at
me like
that's not a [__] workout and you
know you're not lifting weights you're
not running and i'm like dude it is a
workout
for sure
and it's you know one that that i
thought the reason i liked jiu-jitsu
specifically was because it was like a
deadly martial art
you know i could [__]
choke you and like you you're tapping
you're you're asking me like please
don't kill me
you know and that's what i thought was
[__] cool about it
and uh that is definitely one of the
cool things about it you know like
there's there's times where
i don't know yeah like we're we're gun
fighters i get it but
your first line is
should be you like my
my body what can i do with my [__]
vessel that i was brought into this
universe with like versus you
if i don't have a weapon if i don't you
know it's just me and you yeah
one-on-one like let's yeah i mean i got
to see like over and over again just
guys that didn't know how to didn't know
anything and they'd get in a simple
prison or handling situation
and wouldn't be able to handle someone
and the only thing that they would know
to do is like bludgeon them in the head
which is cool that's fine i get it but
when you bring that person into the
detainment facility and they're freaking
all jacked up
and then it turns out that they're
not the person you were looking for or
whatever
and and that just doesn't that's just
not this is not cool and it's not it's
not tactically the best thing to do
because you don't have the control i
mean you can't count on punching someone
or hitting him in the head you can't
count on that solving the problem
whereas jiu jitsu is like yeah no i have
this human under control whereas
you can you know you've punched people
before that
you've nailed them and they shook it off
like it didn't even happen
uh you know the whole thing with like
muzzle strikes i've seen i've had guys
i mean i've muzzle struck plenty of
people but like i've had guys that i've
seen put
the craziest
most aggressive muscle strike on a dude
and have the dudes bleeding yeah but
like still fighting yeah i do think
adrenaline's a [__] hell thing and so
so yeah from the especially when people
are in fear for their life oh yeah
definitely
and they hate you and they hate your
society and they're
a jihadist it's like yeah they're that
muzzle strike if it doesn't knock them
out which sure it is possible but the
idea that that was just going to stop
someone in their tracks 100 of the time
was completely ludicrous
now with jiu-jitsu at least you're going
to have some control more control and
even that's not 100 you know because you
could you know you've got someone that's
really small get someone that's really
big and depending on your skill level
there could be issues there
but um yeah so you finally started
training at a school yeah 2012 and then
you just dove in
all the way yeah i started uh i started
training at a school in 2012. and um
started competing
in jiu jitsu
you know i really once i once i joined a
school
i learned more in six months than i did
in four years of of course nogi rolling
with my buddies you know and i mean that
it was just the blind leading the blind
essentially like who knows the most
today and that's like you guys are all
[__] wrong we're all teaching each
other wrong [__] you know what i mean
so i learned more in six months than i
did that whole time and so i and at that
point i'd really like fallen in love
with jiu jitsu and uh
i started competing all the time and was
doing really well because i was a i was
competing as a white belt you know but i
had already had a shitload of grappling
experience you know with [__] big
strong dudes who were just [__] me up
but now like
now i'm the big strong guy and i know a
little bit and i've i've been in like
hard situations on the map you know what
i mean and then obviously just
the the team guy just will to fight you
know that's always a different level uh
you can tell when you roll with a team
even when a team guy is brand new at jiu
jitsu there's they're still going to be
there you can just tell that they're
different because their will to fight is
is generally higher yeah um so
anyway i started competing a lot and
doing really well and then started
fighting and
doing really well in that as well and
then you know that led me to what i'm
doing now and then you actually took
over when you came home from your you
come to plymouth you took over the
combatives program yeah yep i uh i took
over the combatives program that was
something that you know i felt
like
uh
kind of lacked
in
in the seal teams you know i was very
shocked at that i was surprised at that
you know uh obviously we're
where the seals are the best in the
world you know at what we do and
you know we're gun fighters and
and all that [__] but i would i imagined
that our hand-to-hand
combat you know like everyone thinks
like oh [__] seal he must you know
tap me on the shoulder and i'll and i'll
die you know and it's true
just for everyone who's listening
it's definitely true but uh i hadn't
gone to that school yet so i was like
confused as to why that wasn't a school
or whatever so
anyway i i felt like with at this point
i was i was uh
competing quite a bit and having having
some pretty good success in the uh
fight mma jiu jitsu world
and i'd also had you know real world
experience
you know a lot of real world experience
dealing with prisoner handling and stuff
like that and
um
and i just felt like i felt like i could
bring
um
i felt like i could do a good job at
leading the combatives so um
i took that on board and and they gave
me a shot and
um i rewrote the curriculum for
combatives that we used on the on the
east coast and
um it was it was really good you know
and and i went into it with the
operationally focused
mindset you know not if if you're doing
it i'm all about jiu-jitsu i love jiu
jitsu
however if you're doing a triangle choke
on target something's probably gone
terribly wrong way wrong you know but
it's it's definitely
not
a bad thing to know jiu jitsu you know
what i mean especially as as an operator
you're dealing with human beings and
you're not just you know you're not just
gonna go in and [__]
kill everyone on target you know there
could that happen yeah absolutely but
is that gonna happen probably not and
you're gonna have to deal with human
beings and
you know anything from
just marshaling them to a full-on fight
for your life is
combatives related you know so i covered
all of that in my um
program and
and i really focused on
um
basic simple things that you could
remember
during a time of stress you know like
you're not going to remember 12 steps to
an arm bar something like that when
you're in a situation and you need it
you know what i mean especially in a
combative situation overseas like that's
your adrenaline's going to be going like
crazy it's going to be fast you need
something simple effective and that you
know
that you can
uh remember easily and it's also you
know how it is like in a
in a workup you're you're getting fed
through a fire hose essentially there's
so much [__] you're you're learning and
you're expected to be
proficient and like perfect at all all
of it
before you go out the door so
our combatives we didn't get a whole lot
of time you know it was like a two-week
thing and
so i i really focused on developing
techniques and things that
you know
and would also
be
[Music]
effective effective
uh towards your enemy or your com your
person that you're
dealing with but also mitigate risk to
the operator you know
like
muzzle strikes are great because you can
muzzle strike a hundred people in a row
and your hands feel fine you know you're
not worried about breaking and your
weapon's in control the whole time so
you know that was kind of my focus was
operationally focused mindset and um you
know and
on the west coast i felt like
uh
from what i had seen going out there and
and working with those guys it was a lot
of uh
i felt like more guys were interested in
combatives but there it was more of like
a sporty kind of thing like they're up
in the fight room doing jiu jitsu and
stuff like that and
which which i thought was great like i
said it's better it's definitely better
to
you know have it not need it then need
it not have it and uh so i think that it
was good that guys were doing that but i
didn't think that it was
operationally focused enough you know
like i don't think that you should be
training combatives and pt gear you know
like i had my
i like the program that i set up was all
scenario driven and it was all like
train like you fight you know so
in your in your camis and your boots
with your gear you know because handling
someone and
pt gear versus handling someone and
you know full kit
is totally different as well yeah yeah
well there's
it's um you know i was the the
discussion that used to happen a lot
with all this stuff because believe me i
was in this discussion for a long long
time long time you you reach uh or you
get a ton of [__]
uh pushback people are super people are
super emotional about um
about combatives and you know i would
always like
i wasn't i wasn't as emotional as i
i wasn't very emotional about it but for
me it was just like hey
guys need to know how to do this this is
this isn't about emotion this is about
just the facts of being ready to be be
prepared to being prepared on the
battlefield that's what you need to be
and you know one of the things that
people would say
was
you know um
the like the speed shooting contests
you shouldn't do that because it'll take
away from your operational capability
okay i get it
however who does better on the range the
guy that's like a a
hobby shooter too and then goes out to
whatever cqc he's drilling nails all day
long same thing with uh parachuting like
oh okay so i skydive whatever i'm a i'm
a skydiver on the weekends and i like to
go down and have a ton of jumps i have
you know 2 000 jumps with my slick rig
how do i do when i put a combat
equipment on i do awesome i'm way better
than like a guy like me because i wasn't
like a recreational skydiver whenever i
put equipment on it was like it was it
was a yeah i had to pay attention
whereas the guys that were good
skydivers in the civilian side they were
good same thing with like oh who's gonna
do better
um
in a in a grappling match a guy that
wrestled in high school
with his gear on or a guy that didn't
you know has his gear on he's like it
doesn't matter you get certain skill
level and you're gonna do great and
that's just the way it is now
what you can't do is just say oh well
we're never gonna train with gear on
because there are
certain you know it's like saying hey
we're never going to train with the ghee
if you if someone never trained with the
ghee before
and they go against someone the ghee it
depends on how long that person's been
training with the gee for because hey
nogi and ghee have all kinds of
similarities they have all kinds of
similarities they also have some
differences and depending on
how much you do of each is where you're
going to kind of shake out which one
you're better at but
there's there's so much crossover
between ghee and nogi between
skydiving on the weekends and skydiving
in the teams and shooting on the
weekends and shooting in the teams the
way i always looked at it was train more
train train all the time with everything
you know as much as you can and that's
that's how you get better at things but
yeah that combative thing was um and it
still is it still is i know it's it's
it's
it's hard it's hard to
change it's a shift it's a taboo thing
for some reason and
and it totally depends on who's who's at
the
the head of the table yeah you know what
what what their flavor is what their
take is on it and if the guy
you know is like you or me and then it's
like hey we're all gonna [__] we all
need to know this we all need to do it
and then other guys come in they're like
ah that's [__] stupid we don't need that
yeah and i was i was when someone would
say guys should be working on shooting
i'd say you i totally agree absolutely
you know give us a range you know in the
building and we'll do that in the
building because that's without question
our primary weapon system and
you know no doubt i you want to be a
great shot for sure
guess what how many hours are you gonna
shoot a day
yeah i mean are you gonna shoot 22 hours
a day because you're gonna have some
time at some point we go you know what
let's get some other skills in here you
know we might as well know and like you
said earlier you can't just go you don't
just go on target and shoot everyone
there's uh
there's a
female you know dave burke who's one of
the guys at echelon front good deal yeah
he he has uh he has a story that he
tells about the first time he came face
to face with this like iraqi woman that
did not want him in the house and he's
you know whatever a 18-year marine at
this point and
he didn't know what to do yeah and
it's like yeah you you you need to train
you need to train to handle those
situations and and a lot of people you
know the people are unpredictable
they sure are just totally unpredictable
and especially in a situation where they
don't know like
a bunch of people with guns and body
armor just busted up in their [__]
house like
you think that person's gonna be like
just cool as a cucumber or calm like
i don't know and then when you put hands
on people too
people freak the [__] out and and you
know and you don't need to
just
muzzle strike everyone like you said
like if you do that you're gonna get
shut down real quick yeah you know what
i mean and you're you should be
as an elite warrior you should be
expected or at least i expect people to
handle themselves like and
you shouldn't let this [__] iraqi
woman just walk all over you or [__]
flail around because like you don't know
what to do i can't muzzle striker i
can't shoot her so what do i got to do
you know what i mean and if you've
never and that's just like a woman but
if
now you have like a fighting age male or
something and you know oh if he resists
i'll just kill no that's it's not the
case always you know it's definitely not
like
and uh
you know you definitely don't want the
first time
that you're
handling a human being like that to be
overseas when it's real and they can you
know very easily get to your [__] on
your kit and
you know uh it can be a bad day and
especially like
i tell people you know just think of
like muzzle muzzle discipline and
awareness you know like
when you have your gun even at high
ready and then you're marshaling someone
and they freak the [__] out now all of a
sudden you've got a hot weapon like
going around the room it's just [__]
that there's so much things that you you
need to think about
and
the more you do it the more comfortable
you're going to be with it and
that was kind of my mindset towards it
at what point did you realize you were
going to get out
[Music]
um well
i wasn't i wasn't sure
i i was fighting and stuff and i was
just kind of doing that as as for fun as
a hobby
on the weekends and competing and stuff
like that uh and then i had
gone out and trained
at black house
with some ufc fighters and uh
i had already i had always like looked
at the ufc
you know i was i was always a fan
um and i enjoyed fighting and stuff and
but i'd always looked at those guys like
they were
kind of superhuman or like like it was
like the nfl of fighting like those guys
are genetic freaks or whatever you know
what i mean when you think of someone in
the nfl you're just like man it must be
nice to
be born like that you know or whatever
but fighting's kind of a unique thing
where
i don't know
anyone can do it and
as long as you just put in the the work
you know what i mean so
and being a genetic freak helps too
but uh
but i had gotten there i had gotten the
black house and i trained with some of
the people in the ufc and i was just
like holy [__] like
i'm actually like doing fine like i'm
hanging with these guys and
and um you know talking to them and and
just kind of getting to know some of
these guys and just made it a little
more human you know it's like what did
you do before you're a fighter like oh i
[__] worked at a restaurant you know
i was a busboy or whatever i was uh you
know this that third
and i was just thinking you know and
they're all looking at me like dude
you're [__] navy seal like and i'm
just like yeah but that's all i've ever
known that's all i've ever done i did
right out of high school you know
and uh
and i'm just me you know and i know like
i'm not special you know what i mean
and
it just kind of
made it had a like a shift or like a
realization like these are just people
just like you and
and they just [__] stuck with
fighting and practiced it until they
were good enough
to beat you know the competition and now
they're here
and i was like [__] i i could do that
like i'm pretty good you know and um
yeah and i've been through some [__]
like
i could push myself hard like [__] i
could do this and at the time like i was
i'd already been a seal for a while and
and
you know i got to experience
a ton
and
life and just in war and
and just that whole lifestyle and that
whole thing and
and uh
i was just
at a crossroads you know and i was like
well
i can stay in and make a career out of
this like i was planning on doing i was
planning on staying in for 20 years
um
and you know i can screen and you know
try and make it over there and
or i can get out and and kind of pursue
this and and
at the time i was 29 or yeah i was 27
when i was like making this decision and
um
i was like you know fighting is kind of
a young man's game
and uh
like you read earlier in the beginning
of this like you can't you can't even
pause time you know it waits for no one
and
uh
i was like well
if i
if i just keep down this road i i don't
want to think like what if or like
regret you know
and i was like i've already i've already
been on this path for a while and and
it's cool and all that but
i want to see what else i can do
so i
and i was really [__] struggling with
with that decision for a long time it
was stressing me out and uh then once i
just said [__] it and this
decided you know which way i was going
then the like all that stress like
relief just it was a big reliever
and uh yeah decided to get out and
what year was that
um i got out in 2018
and how many amateur fights did you have
when you were in
uh like 17 or something and then and did
you go pro while you were still in no
they wouldn't let me and that was like
it was so frustrating to me because in
virginia the amateur rule set is the
exact same as pro
so it's day before weigh-ins um you know
all strikes like
no elbows no shin pads you know it's
four ounce gloves no headgear
you know it's it's
it's uh
it's [__] pro five-minute rounds
uh no there were three
three three-minute rounds three-minute
rounds yeah
three-minute rounds
um but some some of them had five-minute
rounds like i fought in north carolina
um so yeah it was no different you know
and uh trying to explain that to like my
command and [__]
and i'm like there is literally no
difference and uh
guess what like a punch from punch in
the face from an amateur feels the same
from a pro that's why i'll tell you what
like those that bruise that came from an
amateur it would have came from a pro
tip dude when i talked to tim kennedy
about this like it's so crazy the army
gave that guy and gives him so much he's
a great guy and obviously a credible
fighter but yeah i mean he was just full
on just getting after it man well and he
still is yeah and they support him yeah
he's all it's awesome
man i ran into
total [__] roadblocks left and right
with my fighting and
um
you know and i use the argument all the
time like guys
brian stan same way brian stanley yeah
he was in the marine corps yeah
officer of the marine corps just out
there fighting in the wec but the uh the
[__] no training tim kennedy they
they sponsored him yeah yeah there were
since like ranger up or whatever yeah
well rangers up is
it's actually tim's com uh company no
tim but for a while tim tim was like
he
i forget the exact story but he he was
sponsored by like the army yeah
for a while they were using it as like a
recruiting tool and then he said listen
you can either keep paying me a
sponsorship or you can just let me come
back on active duty and and they were
like uh that sounds like a good
financial deal for us
so yeah tim tim's
yeah and that's and that's why i kind of
was forced to to choose because i was
running into so much [__] [__]
yeah and um you know like glory
uh
glory had come to town
and they were doing a fight at the
hampton coliseum
and
you know at this point i had already had
quite a quite a few fights under my belt
and had some uh popularity
i guess as a fighter and and they had
heard about me and um they invited me to
to fight on the show and mike tyson was
gonna be there and [__] and i was like
man
this is gonna be a [__] huge
opportunity it's on spike tv too
and uh
i was you know i was like can i can i
fight on this and and
they're like yeah you know we'll we'll
see what we can do blah blah blah and
then
last you know
last minute they they told me no
you know and i was just like if i would
have been your boss you would have been
fighting
i i know and that's that's the shitty
part is like you know it depends on
who's who's at this at the table at the
moment and you know now that i think
about it because i'm just sitting here
thinking like
there's probably a in fact i remember
seeing some kind of policy
that they put in place at some point and
i forget even if it was yes or no i
forget but i remember but my argument
was like all the time was like like just
same one with the skydiving you know
like guys [__] skydive all the time
there's leap frogs you know why don't
why don't the navy why doesn't the navy
use me as a
a recruiting tool you know like i would
i don't want to get out of the teams
i want to stay in the teams but i also
want to fight and like i can do this
like i was ranked number one on the east
coast and two weight classes
you know and i was like
i'm pretty good at this [__] like you
know and
it i don't understand why
we don't utilize this uh utilize me as a
recruiting tool you know go to the
fights set up a [__] pull-up bar hand
out t-shirts and try and hand you know
or go to the
they had me go to the national
uh high school wrestling
contest or a tournament
and they had me do like a combatives
demonstration and and had me go out
there and wrestle with all the the high
school students and stuff
and
yeah i [__] brought it yeah yeah i'll
tell you what man maybe
the uh you know i was up at the
california state championships
last year
or no it was 2019 yeah it was like a
high bunch of hyenas well yeah i mean my
my my daughter was competing and but you
know we're up there and the boys they're
just animals they're animals it's it's
awesome to see yeah it's it's it's those
those kids were [__] talking oh yeah
and they [__] they all wanted some oh
sure they did they were like and and
because i was there and like cami cammy
pants you know and the [__] blue udt
steel shirts and
and uh we brought the pull-up bar and
and you know because the
i think but buds likes they try to get
wrestlers for sure because wrestlers
you know
wrestlers
i don't even want to say wrestlers have
a good chance of making it through buds
because no that's not true it's
definitely not true you have a slightly
better chance than a normal right
however
however wrestlers are used to a [__]
grind and that's probably why they're a
little bit more comfortable and used to
the grind
factor of buds that does not mean
they're used to getting cold and wet and
dealing with all that [__] but they're
used to dealing with the grind so
whatever
and they're competitive so uh so we went
there and yeah all those all these
[__] high school wrestlers are
looking at me like i got something to
prove you know or whatever and
and
i'm out there representing the [__]
seal teams yeah i'm like hey i got
something to prove too let's go young
buck
and uh
so we we now it was a good time but i
was like why why don't they [__]
they're cool with this but not like
fighting like what's the difference like
i don't know
so i just ran into tons of frustrating
headaches like that and that's what re
ultimately decided to you know i just
decided to go go this way and i'm glad i
did but
yeah and that's you know i gotta say
like the seal teams i never tried to
fight pro but like the seal teams was
totally support like i would go and
train at places they'd give me well the
west coast was yeah a lot different in
the east coast
you guys you guys were definitely more
supported on that kind of stuff
extracurricular
things
so you get out
and then when did you go pro
[Music]
right after i got out so you've been pro
for
a year and a half two years right now
yeah a year and a half and how many
fight pro fights do you have i've only
done two pro fights so far um i uh won
my first one by uh tko in the third
round it was a good really good fight um
uh against uh another pro who he was a
pro boxer as well and he had called me
out and kind of campaigned for the fight
or whatever and cool so i obliged and uh
and then uh
and then i did my uh
lfa debut um
i i fight in a sunga i don't know if
you've seen uh any pictures or videos of
me i have unfortunately seen that
you can't unsee it
you're welcome no uh so that's actually
my buddy uh
jeff gum he owns that company
yeah so um
so obviously like i try to support other
team guys and and their ventures and
stuff like that and
you know uh um that was right up my
alley with the uh i thought it was funny
i'll pretty much do anything if i think
it's funny
and uh so i i fought in the sun go which
is for those who don't know it it kind
of looks like a american flag
diaper
sort of thing
but it's sexy yeah well it's from brazil
in brazil there's a sangha and there's a
sangao
and i think the sangha is like the
smaller one and the sangao is like a
little bit but they're they're speedos
yeah they're essentially speeding up
their speedos and
dean lister
because he has so much brazilian
influence in his brain
he went through his phase of training
with a sanggao
and and uh those were some of the worst
years of my life to be honest
no nor south we can't do that today yeah
so uh
i'm not i'm very anti-sangha in sangao
but but you you know you go for it well
i'd actually if if i wouldn't i would
make me want to fight you less yeah if
you were wearing that so you got that
little psychological
it was or it was like confusing to them
yeah you know yeah which is fun i mean
do you remember were you watching like
ufc when everyone was when all the
brazilians were still wearing them in
ufc and they still do sometimes yeah
yeah i've seen some of them yeah but
anyways but i thought it was funny so uh
i so i got a little cup patch sewn into
it so i could put my cup in it and that
was my my new fighting attire and uh
yeah i went out
it couldn't have uh
i don't know it was awesome we'll say
that uh i went out i i fought on lfa on
national tv and um
it was during a military appreciation
fight
and so we did they hosted the fight
at a army base and it was in a hangar
you know with helicopters and we've got
all these people all these active duty
army people in their uniforms and stuff
in the crowd
and uh
you know here i am the the navy seal and
the american flag speedo and and come
out to fight um
and got knocked out for 30 seconds
so it's like it can't get really that
much worse from here so that's cool
but now it was it was actually they
called it the craziest 31 seconds in lfa
history yeah i watched it yeah i watched
it it was it was i don't have a lot of
time to watch fights yeah i had time for
one yeah
but yeah that's uh i i saw blank i think
you posted it somewhere
i posted the whole video i mean which
some which so many people were were so
con like they were like wow i can't
believe you posted this and like you sat
him down first right didn't you sit him
down no so he had a 14 inch reach on me
he was 663 and um [__] big ass dude
and
honestly like i didn't even know like we
were we were real cordial with each
other like at weigh-ins and stuff like
that so i wasn't sure if like we were
going to touch gloves or not you know
because it's always kind of a i feel
like they should just like make that a
rule like you are or you you either do
or you don't it's a rule with me now
but uh
i i wasn't sure if we were going to
touch gloves or not and like kind of
coming out dude he honestly he hit me
like i didn't even know he could reach
me from where he was and it was just
like i think from that that that big
weight i do a big weight cut and uh
i think it just you know just [__]
just put me on queer street right away
and uh
so right out of the gates i i was rocked
and and was kind of f fell down and was
just get he'd swarmed me and i was just
getting punches thrown at me
uh left and right and i'm just kind of
like
seeing stars trying to gain my composure
and then i finally like got backed up in
into one against the cage and
and
gained my composure for a second landed
a one a clean one two and and dropped
him
and then uh ran over like got excited
when i dropped him down kind of
went over towards him and and [__]
just i think probably my coordination
was just kind of off still from just
getting rocked and and i literally just
tripped right over head over
him
over his body and then as we're both
standing up he [__] threw another
punch and that was it
so
and i was just like god damn it i'm a
[__] navy seal on a army base like
fighting in an american flag speedo on
national tv and just got knocked the
[__] out
[Laughter]
but you know i don't know what to tell
you yeah no that's that's hey man you're
getting out there hey yeah that's what
you got to do that's what it is there's
there's gonna be a winner and a loser
that's right
and if you the real losers are the ones
that are actually not getting in the
ring hey you know a lot a lot more times
than not i've come out victorious so uh
it is what it is i i don't it doesn't
slow me down doesn't bum me out or
whatever just
part of it and i i understand that going
into it it's a risk i'm willing to take
and what's your next fight
um we're setting up one looking at
august 25th in riverside hopefully
with the lfa so
hopefully that goes through and
and i'll be
all set to go any idea on an opponent
yet no
i don't care who it is just
i just want someone
yeah i don't care like i i never really
care who my opponent is honestly i don't
i don't look at
really their skill set or i never have
really i don't care because
i've dealt with people just so much and
like combatives and and jiu-jitsu and
fighting it's just like
people are unpredictable and that's what
i stick with like
you may think you have a game plan
figured out and then all of a sudden
they do something different and i don't
even want to be thinking about oh well i
thought he was going to do this and i
had this set up for this and you know
what i mean like i i know what you mean
i will say this
when you find out who your opponent is
you got to watch him you got to watch
some you gotta at least figure out
because there's people that have things
they have their game and if they have
that game and you and you know about it
as you know like if if you know i'm good
at whatever you'll defend that thing
right
and if you don't know it well then i'll
i'll get you in that situation right if
you really let's like um
well anybody anybody if you everyone's
got that thing at their game that
they're good at right and like in jiu
jitsu hey this guy's got a good
guillotine this guy's got a good arm
lock this guy's got good
heel hooks or whatever everyone's got
their little thing
and if they're good at it then that's
what they'll kind of
[Music]
steer you towards
but um yeah so i always and and i always
say look i get it we don't care who the
opponent is
but
when you find out who your opponent is
take a look you know
send it to me let me look at it you know
what i mean because like i've been
watching these
things forever to say hey looks like
this guy's got this and you also have to
watch more than you know watch like
three or four fights and see if they
have any grappling tournaments that are
posted on naga or whatever on youtube
you know you find out what kind of game
they have and if you can do that then
you can learn from it and you can take
it into the you can take it into the
cage with you yeah no i i'm definitely
not opposed to doing that at all i just
uh i just don't
put all my eggs in the bed for sure you
know what i mean that way i don't if if
[__] doesn't go according to plan like
that's cool because they're going to
evolve too yeah they're going to evolve
but
guess what they'll go back to they'll go
back to what they're good at you know
what i mean so that's another thing to
think about
yeah cool um
i uh
so that glory that actual story um
when
i had gotten told no uh that i wasn't
able to do that [__] event and in
hampton roads so i was i was really
bummed out and uh
so i ended up actually just calling the
guy i already like had decided at that
point i was like you know what [__] this
i'm getting out of the navy like i'm
i don't want i don't want to be told
what i can and can't do or whatever you
know what i mean like
and uh so i called the the guy back and
said well when's your next one and he
was like oh we got we got another
another one coming up in san diego and i
said put me on that one
and i so i just took leave and was like
yeah i'm just going to san diego and i
ended up fighting on the glory guard in
san diego i just took leave and and went
out there and did it anyway and uh ended
up knocking the guy out in the second
round
right on yeah that's pretty good outcome
well this is a a pretty good spot
since we're up to current events what
else i know you got your supplement
company you got t-shirts what else how
can people support what you got going on
um
i would say uh the biggest uh
biggest way is probably on instagram um
that's my really my only platform uh i
put out a lot of content on instagram i
do uh my live streams from there i
thought about doing a podcast as well
but but uh i think i'm just gonna stick
to my instagram lives and just kind of
treat him as podcasts or whatever
uh because i like talking and
interacting with with my supporters a
lot and uh
you know so i figure people get bored
just
talking to me for a long time in a room
like this i don't know
but uh
yeah i would say uh
follow me on instagram at uh mitch
aguiar um
and yeah we've got a supplement company
um
our main product is a thing called the
smashing greens that's what i gave you
today yeah and uh
that that actually is a blend of
different organic superfoods um so i
watched this documentary called fat sick
and nearly dead
i don't know if you've seen it or not i
have not it's on netflix and uh
this guy
he he was really overweight and had this
some sort of skin disease and he ended
up getting a juicer
and ended up doing 60 days of just
vegetable juice and
he ended up losing a ton of weight and
his skin disease cleared up and just
like the doctors were just like blown
away at
how healthy he had become you know just
from from doing all this and learned
about micronutrients and all this stuff
so
i was like man
that seems like a cool uh
cool thing like i want to try it you
know i've never fasted before or
anything like that and uh i went out and
bought a juicer and it was
it was
a [__] pain in the ass to clean that
thing like three times a day and i was
having i had to buy like 30 dollars
worth of vegetables every day to make
enough juice to you know put into a
glass that would somewhat keep me full
and i was just like there's gotta be a
better way than this [__] and so uh
ended up going to a vitamin shop and saw
like
organic
freeze-dried wheat grass and you just
add water to it and i was like oh my god
that's so much better you know so i went
and basically picked out a bunch of
ingredients that
i did research on that you know things
that i wanted and
and
put them all into
like a shaker cup and added water and
drank it and did did a fast that way
and uh it was obviously much cheaper
much better like just more convenient
way more convenient and everything like
that
and i just didn't have anything to post
on instagram one day and uh
and so i just shared it i was just like
hey this is kind of a concoction that i
came up with and
and i do my i do a five-day fast like
this and
uh just kind of that makes me feel good
helps me lose weight and then i started
doing that like cutting weight for my
fights
and um
and then
people it just [__] caught on like
wildfire like everyone was like what is
that what is that and then
i was like look i'm not associated with
these companies at all you know like
these aren't i don't get it paid for
this like this is just here this is what
i do and like
put it laid it all out there and i was
like you can get all these products on
amazon or your local vitamin shop or
whatever
and just made it as idiot proof as i
could and i was just getting bombarded
with questions non-stop but but it was
like a lot of people were having like a
ton of success fasting with that and
losing weight
so i was like well that's pretty cool
you know like i'm really i'm down to
help people you know better themselves
and i enjoy like pushing people and
pushing myself and trying to be better
and everything so
um so i stuck with it and just
kept kept answering all the questions or
whatever and then after like a year and
a half or so i ended up
um
making my own you know i was just like
well i might as well [__]
make this my own product and so i found
a way to to kind of make that come to
life and
um took all those products basically and
just put them into one removed all the
fillers and all the [__] in there
and just was like you know i didn't know
anything about the supplement industry
or
anything like that i just never intended
on
on doing that but
just kind of came about and
uh you know delivered a product that was
way more convenient and everyone was
already using and buying all these other
things and now
now it's like my product
and they're able to support me and now
it's like i don't you know i don't have
an issue answering these questions now
that you're buying my product you know
what i mean
so um
now it's been super awesome because
we've had just
a ton of people
lose so much weight and like my brother
lost 110 pounds you know using it so
it really works which is cool you know
and it's really helpful for people and
just changing their lives and like i'm
all about that
and now like it's supporting me
financially now that i'm not out you
know in the navy anymore because i
didn't i didn't get a retirement or
anything like that i just got out so
um
so yeah it's super cool and and uh the
supplement in uh company like
now that i've been in it for a little
while like i'm starting to get more
understanding of it and
and uh we're we're doing
pre-workout
protein bcaas all that stuff like kind
of expanding it and
and um you know now i'm like really
involved with it and and
i'm just treating it like everything
else like i always try to
uh
you know under promise and over deliver
and like i always want to make sure that
like people are getting
like a something good you know i don't
want to ever feel like i jipped someone
or got one over or something like that
like when people come to use my products
like i want them to be
like a [__] satisfied yeah for sure i
mean that's the best policy to have make
the best yeah stuff just don't skimp you
know like my
my
my end game is not to make the most
profit like i want an actual good
[__] product like that my name's
behind you know and i'm proud of what's
the uh what's the website um
you can either go to
smashinfrog.com or
massivesupplements.com supplements.com
either one they go to the same place but
yeah and uh
we got t-shirts and stuff but uh i'm
i'm basically streamlining my t-shirts
because i had massive apparel and i just
made a bunch of t-shirts that
that i
wanted to make you know that were like
personal to me like the mindset is
everything attitude is contagious don't
be a [__] be humble you know these are
shirts that like i've kind of made all
the shirts that i want to make and i
made them i was kind of a t-shirt snob
uh before i had my company and then once
i made my company and like got into the
apparel industry like i just wanted like
really comfortable nice fitting
good quality t-shirts and printed my own
[__] on them and that's all i wear now
but i'm just streamlining it down to a
couple that i like and
i'm actually launching a new brand
pretty soon that i'm very excited about
cool cool right on man yeah so if you
follow me on instagram you'll uh you can
keep up with
all that stuff i got going on and
and watch my future fights and hopefully
i don't get knocked out
echo you got anything
what happened with that dodgeball fight
you're talking about oh man uh it was
oddly enough it was in a church also so
i got into a dodgeball church fight
dodgeball church did you win that one i
did and uh knocked the guy's tooth out
um
we we were there to
uh practice our dodgeball and um we were
taking it very seriously
you know because there was a tournament
coming up that i think had like a 500
prize which
when you're like 16 500 is a million
yeah that'll go along might as well be
yeah go a long way so you know the
stakes were high and uh we were we were
we were there and there were some
local jokers that were just you know
not
taking it seriously and like just
[__] with our practice and stuff and
dude if there's one thing that makes me
angry legitimately angry is when people
aren't taking dodgeball series
you know just
it was there was a time for joking
around there was a time for seriousness
and you know that wasn't the time and
ended up you know i ended up saying
something to this dude and just just
kind of [__] melt off and
you know
my tempers tempers flared and
escalated yeah things escalated and
ended up getting into like a full-on
brawl like one dodgeball dodge dodge
game bro it was a dodge brawl
there you go so thank you it's a good
time well awesome um
hey speaking of
fighting sure and smashing things sure
i mean echo yes
we want to be better at fighting we want
to be better at living what do you got
what do you got for us i got a few
things you know
so we'll start with jiu jitsu right
you like
better
um
i'm starting to like nogi better i would
say just because i feel like it's more
applicable to the cage however um
you know
like jacka was saying earlier i i agree
wholeheartedly i think that
everyone who trains jiu jitsu should
train in a gee as well because
i you know there are a lot of
similarities and i feel like if you only
train nogi
and then you go against someone with a
put a gui on with any sort of decent
skill level you're going to get [__]
choked yeah for sure yeah and uh it just
the gee slows everything down and
it's a it's a totally different animal
and the thing is like you can train in a
ghee all the time and take the gui off
and roll with someone nogi and you're
you're gonna do fine you're you're still
doing jiu jitsu you know what i mean
it's a different game but it's not that
much different but going from nogi to
gee very different
so that's why i think i think people
should definitely train in a gee still
yeah agree yeah both is best for sure
um yeah the ghee adds these elements
that if you only train nogi you're not
used to those elements and if someone
else is used to those elements
all the nogi well most of the nogi
elements are in the ghee you know like
the those elements are there for the
most part of course and clothes you know
like using like in if you're getting a
street fight like you can use clothes
like a ghee right so it gives you even
that many more options yeah for sure
um yeah i agree well speaking of geez
what gee we're gonna get everyone's
doing jiu jitsu now i feel like it's
growing
essentially so what kind of gear are we
getting origin gee you know why we're
getting origin geese because they're
made in america and they are factually
the best skis in the world rash guards
as well okay so where do we get them we
get them at origin main
dot com
that's also where we're getting jeans
yeah by the way and i got mine by the
way
approval level
you know i'm always reluctant to say you
know 101 approval but here i'm gonna say
it 101 approval because they exceeded
literally exceeded my expectations and
your expectations were high or yeah 100
i was like yeah the way you're talking
the way that you know petey does a good
job in building these things up you know
he's taking close-up pictures of the
buttons coming out of the factory that
it's really good so i'm like all right
expectation expectation level is high
these have to be five star jeans
essentially they're like five star plus
some added things that i was impressed
with so yes 100 101 percent approval yes
so jeans
you can get them t-shirts
rash guards supplements
supplements yes so what kind of
supplements joint warfare
which i'm happy man i've been on the
joint warf i think it's been one year
consistent joint warfare krill oil
so approved 100 approved actually
adding value providing value even beyond
what you might think in the beginning
because you know when you know when
we're young you know we're all young
guys or whatever
you don't
care the you know you have muscle
soreness you have all this stuff
whatever the joint soreness is one of
those things that just kind of creeps up
on you but if you're on top of that that
doesn't take it'll take you out of the
game if you're not ready preventative
yeah
and when it comes about i'd get like
elbow stuff from lifting and stuff
but if
if i was on like joint warfare glucose
mean conjoining any one of these things
that they did recommend when i started
grappling by the way if i was on that i
would have never got out of the game
at any point unless the point is
get your joint warfare get your krill
oil and stay on that get your discipline
too yeah fully get your discipline
discipline is like all day now yes sir
that's kind of where it's going
it's yeah it's like yeah guess what i'm
just drinking oh i'm just gonna have
some discipline right
it's kind of i saw you poured this uh is
this what you're talking about yeah yeah
it's just tastiness and goodness
pre-mission is this a pre-workout yeah
it's it's not like a super um
there's not like a super caffeinated
deal because i don't drink a lot of
caffeine and i don't want to drink a lot
of caffeine
so yeah
you little cognitive
a little physical okay and you and you
uh just sip this all day
yeah i don't have like some in them i
won't drink it like after dinner you
know because i th there's a little bit
of caffeine in it and i don't drink a
lot of caffeine so not even in the
mornings when you when you're waking up
nope
it's not 4 30. it says a little bit i
have to
the white tea has some caffeine in it
too so i guess i do drink caffeine but i
don't drink high doses like
like a like a monster energy drink or
whatever yeah
yeah it makes sense speaking of energy
drink we got an energy
it's actually
good for you which is completely
it's like we it's hard to call it an
energy drink because energy drink puts
it in a
in a
category with things that are actually
horrible for you yeah yeah right like
the normal energy drinks that are just
horrible for you this is something that
you can legitimately just drink and it's
good for you yeah so
that's coming out you'll see some cans
of that in the near future oh yeah
that's the good one also milk
if you want a dessert if you want extra
protein in the form of a dessert that's
it monk all flavors i like that jessica
if you want a dessert you have a mint
chocolate
whenever you're dealing with any kind of
putting out something yeah it never goes
according to plan as always longer than
you're expecting or whatever and
i had done uh mint chocolate that was
just i've been a huge fan of mint my
whole life mint chocolate whatever
deliciousness
and uh and i saw that you put out a mint
chocolate and i was like god damn it
everyone is going to think i copied
jacob
i don't have the patty to make chocolate
or they'll probably think like dang i
thought i was the only one who loved
mint chocolate better than everything
else
we all kind of do me and jocko we're
both seals both like jiu jitsu both like
mint chocolate yeah well same thing with
pete right i mean not the navy seal
thing but wait was he into mint
chocolate or peanut butter uh he was
into mint but i think peanut butter see
the peanut butter was kind of like the
[__] yeah
nowhere
smashing well yeah and that makes sense
because in my opinion you know i'm not
disgusted like my favorite dessert is
this or that i'm not that you know but i
will say that when you came out it's
almost like you know you're going public
with your mint chocolate uh love
admiration i was like hey hey me too
but peanut butter chocolate has always
been my close close second yeah easy
money but the one that really the
strawberry
because it's just so
yeah good oh yeah but and strawberry's a
staple anyway you know it's like they
know everything but so is vanilla but
i'm not over here i'm not over here uh
jumping up and down about vanilla yeah
but some people i know some people are
i've got i've got a cinnamon toast
crunch protein coming out and i've got
to think of a name for it because
i don't think i can legally call it
cinnamon toast crunch no i don't even i
don't know
i don't know what the rules are i
thought about thinking of uh you know
growing up uh i always had we were kind
of not so uh financially
gifted yeah you want to call it that or
whatever living in a trailer and uh my
mom
would always get fruity dinobites you
know there you go and cinnamon toast
squares
i used to eat those out of the bag
but that's not what the other kids eat
once i uh
once i joined the navy and started
getting you know a good paycheck i just
i never you know i never
again i always appreciated my cereal
game it was always the the good the real
stuff fruity pebbles
there's no fruity dino bites in this
house get out of here with that yeah
yeah yeah comes in the bag
speaking of that little kids need food
that's why we got warrior kid milk
strawberry boom chocolate yeah let them
eat and be healthy and forgot that jock
a white tee yeah
entertaining yeah yeah my wife gets like
she hits a point in the day where she's
like man i'm considering just to go to
bed right now or to bust out a jock a
white tee and just get after she
literally says that decision point yeah
and i know the feeling but man she's
really committed to it though that's her
go too you gotta take something or make
create a supplement of some kind for a
little power nap
because working on it you know i did
start a rumor that you take naps no i i
freely admit that yeah really yeah he's
very open about it i wrote about it i
wrote about it in uh in the disciplinary
freedom field manual yeah i mean if i'm
really tired i elevate my feet above my
heart and i set an alarm and i'll sleep
for eight minutes and and eight minutes
eight minutes yeah power now yep and if
you go i mean sometimes i'll go 10 but
if you start going 15 20 then then
you're like legitimately you'll feel
groggy but you know the deal man from
like you were talking about sleeping in
a helicopter like you wake up from those
things and you're totally on fire you
know sleep for 10 minutes eight minutes
whatever so yeah i have no problem with
this i the problem with me is uh
i don't know i i tend to nap better than
i sleep
um and then like when i when i wake up
my brain just starts going
and i just once that happens it's just
that's it i'm up
so when you say a supplement for power
adapted like helps you get into like
power nap state like that kind i don't
know
hey we'll look into it yeah
yeah yeah we're working it it could be
your your cinnamon toast crunch flavored
situation yeah have you taken hypnose
yeah so origin so we have we have this
thing called hypnos which is like a
sleep yeah but that's not for now you
need something you need something that's
just good for eight minutes it's you you
take a rail of it and you're out for
eight minutes just fully recharged
i'm working on it well wait but
technically and i don't know this just
seems like this is true power nap okay
you know you have like what the five
phases right of sleep yeah or i don't
know six five or six yeah i don't either
yeah i actually have insomnia yeah so
yeah so you can have some you probably
get jammed up somewhere in one of those
stages right power nap is stage one i
think i'm pretty sure it's only stage
one power nap that depends on how tired
you are well then it won't be considered
a power nap if you're like super tired
and you go boom all the way phased uh
stage five sleep right you went to yeah
do you have sleep or anything no no yeah
i i don't have i did a sleep study and i
don't have sleep apnea but i have
insomnia and it's like i wake up enough
not to actually wake me up but like it's
like i wake up and i don't even know i'm
awake
you know what i mean so i wake up when i
do wake up i'm [__] still exhausted
so it's great
actually so one of the i actually have a
cbd line as well um which i don't know
if you get into the cbd at all not
really no no um but one of the products
that that we're launching is uh a thing
called green dreams
and it's a
rapid dissolve it's a rapid dissolved
tablet that you put on your tongue and
dissolves in like 10 seconds and it's um
25 milligrams of cbd and 10 milligrams
of melatonin
so
but no one would that's that's not for
an eight minute yeah that doesn't sound
like power power now that's the going to
bed situation yeah that's out there
that's a go to bed situation night at
night right on well the opposite of that
is jock white t because you don't take
that before you go to bed maybe after
you wake up in the middle of the day
like my wife or whatever
also if you're into dead lifting which
we all are of course it'll increase it
to 8 000 pounds proven by the way double
blind triple placebo situation
no joke
also we have our own store choco has a
store it's called choco store
we got rash guards shirts yeah
t-shirts you want to represent while on
the path
uh truckers hats yeah for those of us
that
like chokers like truckers hats which
apparently we do they're nice
one size fits all there you go what
about flex fit i did the flex fit for a
while but you know i got a small head
wait flex it has two sizes though i know
yeah so you're gonna get yeah you gotta
get the small medium or the large xl and
i don't know nothing about these you're
not even about that at all don't worry
about turning back to it hoodies
hat snob over here yeah hoodies
lightweight and do you find
use for a lightweight hoodie definitely
all the time you're around yes sir i
agree
everyone agreed with that one
yes some will yes so the ones we have
yes they have zipper i'm a fan of i'm a
fan of the zipper the zipper light
hoodie with the pockets
agree i i honestly i don't even have any
of my own in my apparel line at the
moment but uh
i'm a fan of those yeah
me too yeah well that girl is dang you
know i mean i'm just either t-shirt or
heavy hoodie that's where it's yeah all
functional and i get it you know but
it's like
yeah play some worm guard without for
sure
and uh you know
hopefully it looks good hope you
hopefully you like the design but you
will be representing while you're on the
path a lot of good stuff on there jocko
store.com some patches on there too i
reordered some more patches they're
coming in
i made a mistake
i don't want to go too deep into it but
it resulted in the patches not being
available for a little while
they're going to be available you know
you can't buy what's not available so
yeah good job yeah that's what they're
telling me too and i was like dang okay
all right so you know you learn
something new every day and uh you know
speaking of which right on top of things
trying to be chat i'm gonna be trying to
be
anyway smash the like button
oh my daughter keeps saying that to me
she and she doesn't even know what that
mean i think she halfway knows what that
means she's like smash the like button
and i was like brad the video that
you're pretending to make doesn't even
have a like button no no but you need to
just i gotta cut it out
no no no i gotta stop her from saying
that that's what i'm gonna say but if
you're in the mood to smash the like if
you want to subscribe to this podcast
you can
so do that if you want on wherever you
listen to podcasts don't forget about
the warrior kid podcast which there are
now three new warrior kid podcasts live
at this time yeah good ones stories from
uncle jake yeah stories that teach
lessons an interview with
john bozak the warrior kid artist that
drew mikey the dragons talking about how
to get better at art
how to use art as a
tool to get better at other things yeah
that was good man that was good that
that was like are you do you do any art
uh i did i didn't draw in my books no
but i mean yeah i can draw yeah
he sent me uh man and i'm gonna post
this online and everybody can spoil
paintings oh for real yeah like
have you been into that for like a long
time or is that like a new situation uh
i did my first painting in 2000 easter
of 2016. yeah so kind of new oh yeah
like oh when i was three i did my no no
no no definitely not yeah
jocko has the original logo where i have
the original logo of echelon front and
jocko's design
i actually designed some other stuff too
yeah i've done time to question so he
drew it right but so the the
the disconnect was that i drew it i
didn't draw on with him with my hand i
drew it on the computer like i drew it
on powerpoint
it's so funny because when i first when
he first sent it to me i'm like i'd
of course you drew it on powerpoint you
know it's not like you have one of those
pads and stuff your chocolate you don't
have that kind of stuff so but it's not
as obvious when you get it you just get
the finished product and it literally
looks like my daughter drew it with her
left hand she's right-handed by the way
and but the concept was legitimate it
was sounds like is what the echelon
front logo is at this time that's what
you're pushing and man received but the
newest part of it i tried to explain it
to you yeah nine different times and you
kept sending me back junk yeah and
finally i said okay picture's worth a
thousand words
i don't feel like explaining this a
thousand times yes let's just send him a
a rudimentary sketch
of the concept yes which you then
chiseled out into right you know glory
yeah um emphasis on rudimentary by the
way but the the comedic part of it is
how it looked it looked like a child
drew it so now anytime like if you ask
them oh yeah have you been into art boom
that flashes in my head and he says yes
boom makes it more funny
i'm gonna post it online so we all can
have a good laugh
nonetheless
yes warrior kid podcast is out um that
interview with john bozak is very good
like especially like because it is he
talks about getting like frustrated with
stuff and yeah oh that's how he is
little kids
it was good don't forget about warrior
kids soap from irish oaksranch.com
that young aiden is making on his farm
if you get soap you can
stay clean yeah of course also we have a
youtube channel if you're interested in
the video version and see what mitch
looks like
hell yeah i'm uh
i'm handsome
you might be the buffest guest we've
ever had right
i don't know buffest guess yeah like out
of 185 yeah we've only had like probably
10 or 15
you know how many [__] times people
you and tim kennedy need to fight and
i'm like
have you seen tim kennedy he's way
bigger than me first of all he fights at
85. i know yeah and what do you fight at
70. 170.
i have fought at 185 as well as a
champion at 185.2 um i've i walk around
close to 200. yeah yeah yeah that was no
tim is like 2 15 to 20. he's a big dude
i've i've met him
just in passing um i shook his hand one
time but
yeah he's a big dude and uh but i was
always i always tell you like that's not
well way of like kind of like similar
stories like there's it wouldn't make
sense for us yeah
they just want to see yeah see what up
psychological warfare
is an album with tracks wait wait no
back to youtube we have a youtube
channel i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna uh
what i call explain the value of youtube
you just did you can see what mitch
looks like that's just part of the value
that's just like that a big part of that
i was gonna say don't uh don't
understand that yeah yeah it's huge but
you know we have some excerpts on that
is what i was going to say
you know if you don't want to watch the
whole podcast there's excerpts on there
anyway
some of them are enhanced by echo yeah
so who puts his
art work onto the video and they might
be slightly better than my original
echelon front
maybe logo yeah yeah maybe a little bit
better some of them are over enhanced
yes some people think yeah some people
think they're under-enhanced yes i would
agree with both regardless nonetheless
we have a youtube channel that's the
point yeah and if you want to you can
smash the like button sure
comment uh subscribe whatever the three
things they always say
anyway yes psychological warfare is an
album with tracks if you're running into
moments of weakness
put in psychological warfare you'll
it'll solve your problem no weakness
weakness
uh overcome if the if you want the
visual version of that go to
yeah flipsidecanvas.com brother dakota
meyer has a little company where he's
making
things that you hang on your wall
artistic things some people call them
artistic things
and you can uh get those if you want him
to make a special one yeah
hit him up on twitter
do some custom if it's like if it seems
to get some traction yeah he can put it
out yeah he's good he's doing good stuff
yeah on there yeah i check him out from
time to time
flipsidecanvas.com dig it also on it so
you go to onit.com you get a lot of good
stuff on there including kettlebells
other workout stuff i'm bringing my ring
i'm going to hawaii by the way
for one month
i know people people really don't
they they undersell hawaii i feel like i
feel that was the same way when i went
there for the first time i was blown
away where'd you go
uh maui and um oahu
i'm going to kauai yeah one month i
heard that's beautiful yes sir it is so
i'm bringing the rings
your request by the way that was one of
the selling points of rings is that you
can bring them places too that wasn't
really my request it was a statement yes
statement uh recommendation
recommendation maybe reluctant
recommendation you sure did it was a
real it was a legitimate recommendation
nonetheless i'm taking it i'm taking
them to hawaii anyway the point is
the rings i have from on it you can get
those you get kettlebells you can get i
have this k they have this mineral
electrolyte uh like mix
right
and i think i might have just enhanced
what i call the mega mix it's the
pre-workout mega mix there's two there's
one for jiu-jitsu one for lifting the
one for jiu jitsu is just one scoop of
discipline
a little bit of gatorade so it's a half
gate or eight half water mix optional
gatorade some people they don't like
gatorade some people yeah and that's
cool at all but you can put lemon juice
in there if you want sure
um like i said the discipline the
electrolytes from on it and then uh i
want to add your greens
i'll hook you up yeah that'll be the
mega mega mix that's pre-jiu-jitsu is
there a certain time where you got to
take those greens no just whenever right
get them take them all all day yeah
every day so that's going to be the
pre-jiu-jitsu the pre lifting is
essentially the same thing except you
put like the caffeinated pre-workout in
it if you're into it
anyway
anyway back to on it that's where you
get it there's a lot of cool stuff on on
there you're quite a large a large human
being yourself man looking good yeah but
i don't sound big though thank you i
respect that i'm sorry
does my voice not match how i look
you know i
i can't say because because you saw me i
saw you and you started talking yeah
it's kind of ingrained yeah all right
there you go
maybe not though had you not spoke i'd
been like damn yeah
this dude's probably [__] got a
jacked voice yeah yeah like joking or
something yeah
but it's melodious it's not jack that's
all right i have a i have a high-pitched
voice melodious yeah very melodious yes
interesting
anyway yeah got some books
way the warrior kid three it's out it's
called where there's a will
teaching kids about how to go harder
that's a little lesson in this book you
know you got to push harder and also
teaching them about their ego and how
their ego will get them in trouble
everyone wishes they would have learned
about ego
earlier because it makes your life
better
of course there's a way the warrior
could want to wear the warrior kid to
mark's mission those books are for kids
to learn to get on the path
if they're a little bit younger than
that you can get a mikey in the dragons
they can learn about how to overcome
their fear there's actual
pragmatic
protocols that you can take as a human
being to overcome what you're afraid of
why not learn that when you're five
years old
that's my question why not because you
didn't know about about the book mikey
and the dragons now you know about it
your kids are just out there conquering
fears which is a positive thing
yeah and that's a good one too because
you can like you know if you have a
bedtime routine you know you read to
your you know four or five-year-old
before they can read it's one where you
can read it not only can you read the
whole thing if you want it's like a
fifteen
minute you know but they'll wanna hear
it again
so it's like a you know so when you're
real while you're reading it over and
over again that lesson will be inst you
know ingrained in instilled deeper and
deeper rather than just one of the many
books repetition yeah exactly right
uh then we got the disciplines freedom
field manual
if you go hey jocko can you post your
workouts
yes they're in the disciplinary freedom
field manual hey jocko what do you think
you should do in a situation like this
oh it's in the discipline equals freedom
field manual hey jacob what do you eat
it's in the manual
what's your sleep routine it's in the
middle do you take naps it's in the
manual it's all in there
so this one goes freedom field manual
the guide to getting after it
if you want the audio version of that
it's on itunes
and the amazon music and all the mp3
things then of course we got extreme
ownership
and the dichotomy of leadership written
me by me and my brother leif babin
those are gonna help you
become a better leader in your business
with your family and in your life watch
it happen
of course we have echelon front which is
my leadership consultancy and what we do
is solve problems through leadership
because all the problems that you're
having in your life right now in an
organization
are leadership problems i don't care
what they are and if you want to solve
those problems you have to fix your
leadership and that's what we do it's me
leif babin j.p danelle dave burke
yes
flynn cochran mike cirelli mike bima and
jason garner go to echelonfront.com
for details we also have ef online
which is online leadership training
which
is something that's hard to comprehend
how are you going to take
leadership and teach people leadership
from
an online thing an online training
program well you read about it you take
tests on it and then you get put in
scenarios interactive scenarios on
the computer where you have to make
decisions so
that's ef online
then we have the muster
which is a leadership
conference it's a leadership event
something like throwing a gathering down
sure it's all it's all it's actually the
mustard is what it is yeah it's a
mustard it is it is but it's the mustard
the mustard so look the muster
leadership they've all sold out
and they're all going to sell out the
next one is september 19th and 20th in
denver after that december 4th and 5th
in sydney australia check out
extremeownership.com
for details if you want to come don't
wait
to register because then you won't be
able to go and you'll be mad at me
and i and you'll send me a
let's say you're my friend let's say
you're someone i actually know sure
and and we're doing a muster up in san
francisco and you send me a text that
says hey sorry for letting you know late
uh you said you were gonna hook me up
with some tickets it's cool i can make
it and i'm bringing two friends yeah
yeah
and i'm like well first of all
no
because it's literally sold out it's not
like hey it's sold out but we can still
let people in that's not sold out it's
sold out yeah
so don't wait
and then of course we have ef overwatch
where we take
proven combat leaders from special
operations from combat aviation and put
them into companies in the civilian
sector that need leadership leadership
is the most important thing on the
battlefield why not get
battle tested leaders to help out you
inside your business
go to ef
efoverwatch.com and if you want to ask
me a question us a question you want to
give me an answer did i mess something
up today probably
you want to let me know about that
please bring it
mitch as he said he is on instagram
mitch underscore aggie r a g u i a r
and echo and i are
well we're on twitter and instagram
and on
[Music]
echo is that echo charles and i am at
jocko willing echo anything else
nothing else thank you thank you guys
for having me very much i really
appreciate the uh hospitality and
opportunity
right home awesome well mitch thanks for
coming on appreciate it and uh thanks
for working the teams
and i'm sure you're gonna keep putting
forth maximum effort to smash people in
the cage look forward to seeing that
and to all the other vets out there and
to those that are still in uniform thank
you for standing watch over freedom
for our great nation and to our police
and law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers in border patrol
secret service and all the first
responders
i travel around the country and i run
into you all the time
and i see what you're doing out there
working and working hard and the reason
that we live safely here in our country
is you
so thank you for holding the line here
at home
and everyone else out there remember
that you can't hit the pause button
and it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter at all if you get
knocked down or you get tripped up or
you think that something isn't fair it
doesn't matter you still don't get to
stop
so get back up
bite down on your mouthpiece and go get
after it
until next time this is mitch aguiar and
echo and jocko
out